there's no time
13 o clock
[Music]
hey there ladies and gentlemen it's
episode 174 yeah this one's kuklinski
the Iceman Richard the Iceman Iceman
Kuklinski probably one of the most
notorious most renowned mafia hitmen of
all time as ever it's killing that's
ever been apprehended at least and
according to this story I'll tell you
what well if I was ever locked up with
this dude in the same cell with him I'd
be calling him mr. Kirkland yes sir no
sir dude [ __ ] kill you dead and [ __ ]
well the reason that I wanted that I
wanted to do this show eventually was
because you happen to mention I don't
remember what show it was on but it was
like we were talking about some other
serial killer or something like that and
you said the only one of these dudes
that ever scared you was this guy yes
yeah I mean he's dead now but I mean
call he was big intelligent he's a very
very large person well-trained he knew
his craft well cold blooded yeah he did
not give a single [ __ ] no and and not an
amateur by any stretch of the
imagination this dude lives to
terrorized gangsters that's what he did
and anybody else who got in his way
yeah I mean the thing about it is that
while I think that probably some of the
murders that he has claimed that he
committed like the number of the murders
I think is probably exaggerated but I'm
not doubting that he killed a lot maybe
he was could ultimately he was convicted
of killing six people and you know at
varying times he is confessed to killing
between 100 and 300 people altogether I
don't know if the number is that high
like I said he might be exaggerating cuz
you know later god he's me because there
were just a lot of contract killings and
some of some of it was just if you
pissed him off he killed you yeah he was
a gold face about it do he do it in
traffic yeah he would do it in
nightclubs he would do it behind
nightclubs he didn't give a [ __ ] that
was the strange thing about him is that
yes he made his money as a contract
killer as well as doing other criminal
activities as well um
but it just seemed like if you just like
annoyed him a little bit he would hope
one he would hold the grudge for a
really long time
yeah um he had anger issues to put it
mildly um but you know you cut him off
in traffic he'd just kill you well he
hated other gangsters and he didn't have
any friends cuz he knew eventually he'd
kill you anyway yeah so but I think he
did end up saying that he killed all of
his friends everybody he knew and that
one friend was the guy that ended up
right indirectly getting him arrested oh
you didn't have to know you too well
he'd probably have to kill you yeah
it'll all make sense we took and he
didn't seem too broken up there this guy
I was this guy seems like and this is
why I kind of find him really
fascinating he seems just like a perfect
sociopath you know what I mean yeah this
is a dark warrior he would have this guy
would have made a good soldier also and
can maybe Special Forces if he was the
right kind of guy he's not the right
kind of guy yeah but he's the right kind
of guy to work for organized crime
syndicates you know yeah he could work
yeah it seemed like he was that kind of
guy he wasn't some guy that just you
know depended on you know firepower to
get him through you know he would kill
you barehanded or just with a damn piano
wire tire iron a tire iron grenade
allegedly poison poison anything he was
big on that I think whatever it was to
handle a guy with a pool cue crossbow
yeah it's just he wasn't particularly I
didn't like to have a pattern that way
it always looked like a different person
yeah and I think that's why it took them
so long to kind of like connect all
these crimes is being committed by one
reason he was a physically powerful guy
he could just choke he into oblivion
yeah yeah he was a very very very large
yeah yeah and very scary um and I would
write very intelligent yeah prefer you
know when I talk about a Rhodes Scholar
yeah he didn't finish pricing out his
situational awareness and his knowledge
of human humans and human behavior was
very good yeah did not want this guy on
your tail you're a dead man
yeah
have one missus car and like I said it's
like even though as I said since he was
convicted ultimately of killing six
people and probably killed more than
that they're not really sure how many
because some of the [ __ ] that he said
later is probably not true but you know
even though six people that technically
puts you in the category of serial
killer but because he did not have like
a psychosexual motivation yeah um not
really assume not really a serial killer
in that sense like in the psychological
sense yes he was a contract killer and
he like took money for hits but he also
just killed people just because of anger
yeah a lot everybody we pretty much
talked about so far with just like some
kind of sicko nasty sucker you know they
don't really scare me even though
they're [ __ ] gross you know I mean
other than they make you mad they make
you be mad a lot of them yeah this one
scares me I mean I just wouldn't go for
it wouldn't go up this you know yeah I'd
be taken by ambushed in a pre-plan yeah
waiting for him to walk by that anybody
can do that but you don't want this dude
on your tail this was this is the reason
this guy's the real deal well in the
scariest even if he's lying about half
the [ __ ] yeah just feel the real deal
well because the thing the thing that
scariest about him I think is that one
for a long time he kind of got away with
being a contract killer and his family
not knowing like a lot of people just
thinking he was just a regular family
guy or like a businessman
yeah um also he seemed really like I
said he had really bad anger issues and
you weren't really sure what was going
to set him off because like his family
would be like you know a lot of times he
was like normal he was like really nice
and stuff like that but you never knew
like when he was gonna flip he could
trick you can just click out so it's
like you might say something that he
didn't like and then he would remember
that and then like later on you can
walking down the street and he would
just shoot you in the back of the head
you know I mean so it's like that's what
made him scary was that he wasn't
predictable he could do it like it was
nothing
and he could get away with it
consistently yeah what he did and he had
a method away with yes I mean like I
said it took them a very long time cold
calculated yeah
and although like I said I do recommend
because HBO did a three-part series
about
him like over the years I think like one
PAR came out in the 90s early 2000 and I
think they're all on YouTube I watched
them so like somebody like put them all
together it's like two and a half hours
and these are just like interviews with
him like one third of it is like a
psychiatrist interviewing him another
third it's like a writer and not the
third and he's just kind of like talking
but all the [ __ ] he did and like I said
the creepy thing about it is that he
just has he's just very very calm he
doesn't really get upset about anything
it's like he doesn't really seem to like
feel anything about anything what was
his job and and he enjoyed his work I
guess and it was just kind of routine
for him yeah most of it the thrill of it
I think was long gone but he'd get mad
yeah they do that yeah if you made him
mad even if you didn't know him chances
are you kill you're right then yeah and
get away with it yeah you had to do it
yeah so that's like I said that's what
and and I'd been wanting to do a show
about him for a while because like I
said when when you were talking about
him and I had remembered like reading
about him and seeing like the interviews
like back in the day and I was like yeah
we need to do a show about that guy and
it's like we'll do it in December
because he's called the Iceman yeah you
know all right so anyway before we get
into that let's do a couple of shout
outs like to say hello to our latest
patron whose name is Rebecca hey there
thank you very much
right I also like to give a shout out to
Jason for giving us a very generous
PayPal donation as a Christmas present
yeah very very much appreciated yeah
yeah and like if people you know if you
watched our matinee show what's I think
it was on the matinee show my [ __ ]
car and then actually more than that we
put in another basically another two
honey oh that's right yeah we was dead
also we found out yeah and I put a new
gas cap which I think is I think that's
where that damn vacuum leak was yeah
because we've had a vacuum leak for a
really long time they're fighters
yeah I got a new mounting system for the
battery so it's not rattling around it
yeah
my poor car yeah it's old but it's still
like it's only got 3,800 serviceable
138,000
it's a 2004 Ford Taurus
yeah that's a little sleeper car you
know it's almost kind of like but you
just kind of get lost in the crowd with
that thing but I'll tell you what man
those Ford Tauruses they were around
forever it's still look yeah the same
car from that came out like in 84
basically and I mean to be fair just
rock-solid you can rot you can drive
forever I mean to be fair I haven't put
that much money into that car now like I
bought it used for a lot of bang 400
bucks or something um I've had I've had
to put very little money it's I mean
it's like fairly reliable yeah the
alternator went out and [ __ ] like that
maybe the first time I saw one of those
things man was in Robocop we thought
that was the most futuristic [ __ ] car
ever was a damn I try how to do that I
take your car paint it flat black yeah
semi matte black and put those OCP
stickers on there you like that you can
write like Robocop okay
well you do you drive that yeah okay
yeah he's crazy
do you know me at all yeah don't do it
with paint spray rubber what do they
call that [ __ ] yeah because they could
just peel off what I'd call it yeah oh
my god don't you yeah yeah that'd be
[ __ ] awesome you should do that well
I hadn't even thought of that
OCP stickers on it yeah now I think it
had a blight bar on it though I we
couldn't get away with that well no we
probably not legal people pretend we're
a Roebuck now I really want to do that
why did you give me that idea I can't
believe you thought that I wouldn't
drive a car that was painted like the
red card Robocop of course I would be
it'd be easy to paint that car that
cause I wouldn't holy [ __ ] easy to paint
that car that car thing is is this semi
matte black it looks dirty when it gets
dirty it looks very dirty yeah I know
that's something and I Pharrell let that
car get dirty I yeah he said he took it
to the car washed and it gets hot true
he would burn you up in Florida we're
not gonna do that
well you suggested it yeah that new that
new a/c is it's just blowing ice cubes
good yeah that's like in Florida I mean
it's not good now because it's winter
but it's letting your warranty on it but
you know we'll be we'll be thankful for
it next July I'm sure I have $700 where
the air
like it better be [ __ ] cold for 700
[ __ ] dollars alright so yeah so uh any
water spots I'm not peeing sure drops
coming off the bottom of this drink he's
just like I don't know you're protesting
a lot now look at fell look look at yeah
okay I see it
we'll see you now the cool thing is now
if you want to do you actually I could
just piss and everybody drink yeah cuz
you're like so much your the front load
in that [ __ ] yeah that she would make
its way out good playin [ __ ] pornhub
[Laughter]
everything's gonna be a port yeah
everything's a [ __ ] fetish yeah that
would be really funny now is that now
I'm that's another good idea so if you
put in the chair I'm gonna put it up or
no no man all right I'm just alright so
again thank you Rebecca and Jason for
your contributions to the show Christmas
special coming up yeah we were just
talking about it earlier cuz I'm you
know how I do it's like I I knew I was
like okay Christmas special I had it
like penciled into the calendar and then
I'm like oh [ __ ] that's like the next
show what am I gonna do it's gonna be I
think it's gonna be ghosts ghosts got
Christmas ghosts and ghosts or we might
do [ __ ] about like like you said I don't
elves little people yeah someone yetis
maybe yeah like you know winter adjacent
gonna be a variety show
well like the Thanksgiving one we did
where everything was kind of like
colonial America [ __ ] I just you know I
like to have like kind of a loose
structure cuz that otherwise I don't
know what I'm gonna talk about and I'll
just sit here going um yep but yes so
another thing that I want to announce is
that if you are a twenty dollar up
patron and you know who you are
um probably this like get me if your
size of your t-shirt by the end of this
week some of you like eight or nine have
you ever already done that and that's
awesome I appreciate that but there's
still a few of you that haven't I sent
out notes on I sent out messages on
patreon so if you want a shirt then
send me your size by the end of the week
because we're gonna order the shirts and
start printing them and then start
mailing them sometime before Christmas
we got the design where is that it's
over there like behind my chair like in
the box it makes sense to them though
it's just a clear piece of plastic with
a design on it well yeah it's
transparency it's gonna look good I hope
so I like the transparency came out
really nice I was like super happy about
it so yeah and thanks to one of our
subscribers might be a patreon man pay
Trevor gave us the web address of a
[ __ ] service to them it was it was
Mary okay man yeah yeah she gave us the
jiffy shirts yeah definitely that's what
we're gonna use from now on because yes
service they have like a bunch of stuff
and it's cheaper than yeah I mean I
don't mind going to Michael's if I have
to because they usually have a lot of
shirts but sometimes they don't have
enough like of the sizes we need and
that we can fill an order through that
yeah it'll be much much easier and
there's like a lot more um variety of
like different kinds of shirts you know
which is handy um also I mentioned this
before but I think starting in the new
year
I'm gonna start doing just as kind of
like a little sideline thing another
little show that'll just be like me
reading scary stories usually like old
ghost stories some of my own stories if
you want to submit one you can do that
too and I'll put your name in the name
of the story at the end credits I
probably think I have four or maybe five
episodes done so I'll start putting
those up probably new year I don't know
I've decided what day to put them up or
anything like that I think that's
probably about all the shoutouts yeah
alright we can talk about the finance
kita so let's talk about Richard Leonard
Kuklinski mr. kuklinski nee mr.
kuklinski sir
like I said at least he's dead now so
it's like her doctor got a heart attack
or something
uh yeah although he told his family that
he had been poisoned because he did die
it like a very when he was gonna be
testifying against another gangster that
could be true so I'm not sure how true
that is they did do an autopsy and they
they thought it was just a heart attack
okay but Heath
he seemed to think that someone was
poisoning him and it was kind of
convenient like what he died and like
the gangster that he was supposed to
testify against actually they the case
against him collapsed because he was
like their main witness so yeah
Kuklinski commonly known as the Iceman
and we'll get into why that is later on
also known as the one man army yeah
because he was it was a huge dude he was
six foot five almost 300 pounds really
really big scary-looking he can't come
at you anyway he wanted to yeah he
didn't he wasn't a guy that was
dependent on firearms no like I said he
would use anything yeah and he liked to
experiment with different things seemed
like he was just kind of curious about
his do with some mouse man he would take
orders yeah like he had a specific order
I want this guy killed in a certain way
and need to ego okay you just give you a
price yeah and some of that she was
gruesome one thing that he said and I'm
gonna say this right it's just like is a
little bit of a teaser I'm not sure if
this is real or not because like I said
he did exaggerate some stuff cuz he said
that he was involved in some kind of
famous mob murders that they think was
not that likely for him to be involved
in you know what I mean but he did say
he didn't say who this was but he said
one time I got an order to kill this one
guy and the person who ordered the hit
apparently they wanted to send a message
so they wanted this guy's tongue cut out
and then stuck up his ass
yeah because I guess he was talking out
his ass they wanted him to taste his ass
like that he had done not too much just
yeah just as an example I don't know if
that really happened or not but that was
one thing that he said about like taking
orders well the other stuff you said was
true so I think it's true well like I
said it's it's hard to say because some
of the stuff like he says W said that he
did they didn't know having eaten the
record of that crime you ever happening
yeah one and two he also said that he
was involved in three very famous mob
murders including that of Jimmy Hoffa
and they don't think that that is very
likely all right you know I mean so it's
hard to say I mean he did do horrible
[ __ ] they
just don't know if he exaggerated it
somewhat like later on because he did
get like a lot of like people coming to
his jail cell and wanted to talk to him
and [ __ ] some of the stuff that he did
he leave a body in a certain location
and it was never found and we would
probably get into that a little bit
later yeah and he's like somebody found
it but he I don't know who it was
somebody took it away yeah I was not the
one in the barrel one barrel yeah but
that's I think that scum might be
plausible yeah I think he did do that
one I thought well I think the guy that
guy um I don't know he was actually
indicted for that murder I don't know if
he was convicted because they never did
find that body yeah but that barrel sat
out there for about a year I think he
said did he it was a long time I don't
know I think I just think somebody just
sent the barrel to the dump never
checked and never checked it yeah that's
possible this is a [ __ ] up check all
right so let's start talking about his
childhood
now even though like I said even from
you know a psychological point of view I
guess you wouldn't really call him a
serial killer maybe more like a mass
murderer contract hitman whatever but he
did have a very serial killer II
upbringing you know what I mean in his
movie was kind of like yeah he did have
a lot of that kind of [ __ ] now he was
actually born really poor his dad
Stanley was a Polish immigrant and
worked on a railroad he was like a
brakeman his mom was actually Irish or
her parents were Irish she was born here
and she worked in a meatpacking plant
when she was when Richard was a kid now
this household was very very abusive his
dad like many serial killers was a drunk
beat up on the wife and all the children
the mom was also allegedly abusive used
to beat richard kuklinski with a broom
handle you know breaking like sometimes
they so hard that the handles would
break also there was there was there was
kind of [ __ ] between you know the mom
and dad - it's like I can't it's weird
because one source I said said read said
that the
I stabbed the mom in the back but then
another source I read said that the mom
stabbed the dad in the back I think it
was the mom stabbing the dad like during
an altercation yeah
the mom was also and this is another
thing that you see with a lot of these
types of killers was very very very
religious very very very strict you know
thought that that's how you raised a kid
you just like you know beat sense into
them some people get mad when I talk
about when I associate violence with
religion and they go no religion isn't
about violence that's not nobody saying
that yeah what ends up happening a lot
of times and some of these really poor
violent families the dichotomy between
the violence and the [ __ ] maybe
sexual abuse makes a really strong
dichotomy with this religiosity yeah so
the kid grows up with inner conflicts
yeah you know you got to have one or the
other if you have two extremes at the
same time it [ __ ] them up even worse
yeah I mean and that's definitely seems
to be the case here this is not you know
the this is not a good situation by any
stretch they mentioned and like I said
I'm not excusing his later stuff but you
know it when you grow up in a household
like this and I'll kind of get into when
he tries too bad there's no conflict if
you get good there's no conflict if
there's good and bad happening at the
same time there's a lot of conflict yeah
it's not one thing or the other yeah so
it's like it's like petting a dog and
beaten it at the same time it's it makes
it go insane yeah well yeah because you
never know what to expect ever know it's
like it causes neurosis right is what it
does it does it in animals it does it in
people right um you know what I mean so
so I feel like there was some of that
going on too
and you know it's it's weird to think
about because kuklinski I mean he was
such a big imposing dude later on but if
you see pictures of him when he was a
kid and I did find one um he was
actually pretty small he was like a
little bitty small kid he had kind of
you know his little ears were sticking
out and cute little kid but you know
even though like he was an altar boy
when he was a kid but very early on he
star
you know showing cruelty to animals
one thing that he said he would do and
this is like horrible and this like
really really upsets me he said that he
used to find cats in the neighborhood
and he would tie their tails together
with rope and then he would hang them
like over a lot like a clothesline or
something like that and watched them
like fight and kill each other yeah he
would also take neighborhood cats and
throw them in the incinerator in their
building and just watch them run around
and try to get away from the fire and
then they would all burn up yeah
he would also torture stray dogs that he
found in the neighborhood while thinking
about killing his dad because he really
wanted to kill his dad now his dad
Stanley as I said was very abusive and
actually they think that his dad killed
Richards older brother Florian when
Florian was 8 years old even though he
was never arrested for it they could
because they told the authorities that
the kid fell down the stairs but the kid
did die and they think that the dad beat
him to death
yeah well that would be a huge moment in
a boy's life uh dad beat your older
brother to death yeah that's what I mean
this is late that would send you down a
certain path where well he had the power
you can do whatever you want and that's
yeah and I think that's kind of like I
said this was like a bad situation all
around and when he like when he was
older and he talked to the psychiatrist
dr. Park Dietz like on the last HBO
interview that psychiatrist told him
he's like well he's like what I think
your problem was was that you were
probably born with this type of
personality where you just have this
kind of like innate fearlessness or you
don't really you know care about what
happens to kamikaze yeah and he's like
now that can go well like his pee he's
like people like that like we're
successful they you know race cars or
their test pilots or something like that
he's like sometimes that can be good but
if you are like that and you are raised
in a situation
where your parents are just [ __ ]
beating on you all the time and he was
also bullied in school because like I
said even though he was very large later
he was kind of like a little skinny
little kid so he got bullied a lot in
school and he kind of learned from a
very early age that violence was how you
solved problems I was always under the
impression because of the way he grew up
and the way he handled things and based
on what he said he that he saw himself
as a man fighting evil that's part of
what part of the way he saw himself like
his dad was a great when he was a little
kid his dad was a huge menace yeah a
Darth Vader type figure yeah so you have
to become strong and terrible yeah then
I mean fearsome to over to overcome
something like that and he's fantasizing
buddy he wishes he had the power to kill
his dad yeah you know but he doesn't cuz
he's just a little kid so he has to kill
things that are weaker right now but
Tommy was an adult he started killing
people who slided him picking him off
and you didn't know much even like to
get him mad no but when you look at the
details of the stories especially at the
beginning he's in a real thug
environment and these are other bullies
and thugs that are [ __ ] with him
mm-hmm
he's making him pay yeah so he sees
himself in a way of kind of like a a
warrior
you know Nemean almost kind of like a
samurai he's standing up for his own
honor he's doing what you're supposed to
do which is kill the enemy yeah you know
it's a very soldier type mentality you
know yeah it's a tribal warrior
basically is what you're dealing and
like I said in the right circumstances
that's a good quality so that's a good
quality to have of course you know but
like I said it depends on the context
yeah you know he's not doing it for a
nation or a state or anything like that
with any kind of legal sanctions he's
doing it for himself
yeah yeah but you know what that's all
he knows yeah I'm Connor I'm forgiving
Kuklinski good I mean I can I can
understand I I can't like I can't
forgive him because he just you know if
he had just killed other gangsters I'm
talking about at this point well at this
point like I said one what ends up
happening he becomes eventually
indifferent to it he'll just kill
anybody yeah and he really like I said
he really did not seem to feel anything
about I mean he even told the
psychiatrist that and he knew that that
wasn't right that there was something
wrong with him but he didn't really
understand why that was because he's
like well because the psychiatrist would
ask him he's like well how did you feel
when you like dismembered the guy with a
chainsaw or for example and he's just
like I didn't feel any way about it he's
like it smelled kind of bad I put some
glue under my nose that's like who's he
was just like very matter-of-fact like
he didn't really well yeah he had kind
of burned out that those centers in his
brain yeah but it was it was normal for
him you know yeah that's what's so scary
about him he just like he didn't care
about anything it's just like it didn't
affect him at all but we'll tell more
about his story let's go back yeah a
timeline so um yeah so he was a little
kid like like I said his older brother
Florian was killed by his dad allegedly
when Florian was eight years old he also
had a younger sister named Roberta who
as far as I know turned out okay
but he also had a younger brother named
Joseph who in 1970 was actually put in
prison for raping and murdering a
twelve-year-old girl he raped her
then he threw her and her dog off the
roof of a building who did this his his
younger brother that's right that's
right and for a while like later on in
their life after they were actually at
the same prison yeah but they asked him
like if do you ever talk to your brother
and he's like not really he's like
sometimes I walked out I forgot I was in
a little she was in a real shitty area
but I think it was Jersey City Jersey
City yeah it was like it was very very
poor they were just me back in those
days it's probably like moved up since
then but I think back in the 60s it was
it was pretty [ __ ] rough yeah it does
seem like it was a kind of the projects
yeah even back you go into the 70s even
New York itself as a [ __ ] slum yeah
you know yeah I mean I was in New York
people notice it's gentrified a lot to
you then and I mean I was even there
like many years ago probably 10 or 15
years ago and it's like way nicer than
it used to be back in the old day now
when I was in New York I guess I was
about
years ago and it's like a rich
neighborhood yeah but back in the day it
was like as bad as Detroit Detroit's
gone now you know a nice go to trace to
live in Detroit yeah Troy is basically
gone now you know there's just that
whole culture is dead yeah so you know
it's just sitting there on [ __ ]
welfare but it's wait Detroit was where
I seen that's way New York kind of way
your art was worse actually cuz it's
just well yeah famous for being a New
York was worse like that I mean even if
you see like movies cuz we were just
talking about like you know the Larry
Cohen movie God told me to and stuff
like that which was you know from the
70s you can see you know the scum eNOS
of like New York and the 70s even up to
like the late 70s early 80s yeah but
it's really nothing like that nothing
like that anymore it's not all posh and
gentrified it's all gentrified and all
these slick and you know I mean I've
been there lots of they got liberals in
Detroit now owning in New York now not
back in the 70s it was just [ __ ]
criminals well like I said everything
was dirty there was rats everywhere I
mean it's you know it's still like that
in this lace rocketship it was like I
said I mean I own prostitution four foot
high here probably 10 or 15 years ago I
I mean I used to go pretty regularly but
um you know I I saw one rat the whole
time I was there like just kind of I
want to see the way I used New York New
Jersey used to be back in the day go see
a movie had Dustin Hoffman called
Midnight Cowboy that's the way it was
like yeah I remember it doesn't Hockman
yeah it was like like I said it was kind
of famous for being like yeah people
would just die at TV you know yeah well
I'm like look at like this like money
looking like the early like punk rock
scene it sold like around CBGB's and
stuff like that whereas you knows listen
you too blondie and The Ramones and
stuff like that I mean they were like a
squatting and like essentially abandoned
buildings and just like laying there on
mattresses and doing heroin and [ __ ]
like that it was like that you know I
mean and I'm not saying there's not
parts of it that are still like that but
rat and roach infested yes but I mean I
went kind of all over the place and it's
like it's not there's hardly any of that
all right so like I said kook lights guy
don't think he finished school but he
just but he was like you know fairly
intelligent he got bullied a lot at
school
kind of get into that a little bit later
when I get into his like criminal career
I'm just kind of talking about personal
life right now
now it's weird because a lot of [ __ ]
that I saw did not mention you know they
mentioned his wife Barbara who you know
she there's like a lot of interviews
with her like talking about him and
stuff like that but what a lot of [ __ ]
doesn't mention is that he was married
to someone else when he met her he says
she was actually his second wife even
though like a lot of like I even saw I
think I saw a documentary and it's like
I don't even think they mentioned that
but he had a wife named Linda she was
nine years older than him and they
actually had two sons now as I said he
had dropped out of school but he was
kind of working you know you know
working-class type jobs he was working
at a trucking company and he met Barbara
Patricia was her maiden name she was
like a secretary at this trucking firm
that he worked at so he like fell in
love with her and they started dating
and he eventually like left his wife and
married Barbara in 1961 now the thing
about this and I think this happened
before they were married Barbara because
there's a like a lot of interviews with
her on various documentaries and [ __ ]
she said when she first met him that
she's like he was like um pretty much
everything you'd want like in a man he
was like really romantic it's like she's
like he brought me flowers all the time
it's like he always wanted to be with me
he was really awesome and all this other
kind of [ __ ] but while they were still
dating she kind of saw the dark side of
it you know what I mean because
apparently they had been going out for a
while and she's like most of the time it
was good but he seemed real like he
would flip like I said he just said you
know most the time he was just really
nice and it's like you'd never think
anything and then suddenly he'd get a
wild hair across the crack of his ass
and boom he would just be changed like
that she's like he was like Jekyll and
Hyde I think he had kind of like schizo
upbringing he had a bunch of like almost
kind of like PTSD and you can't go
through these flashbacks he'd think
people were gonna betray him or the
you'd think the PA talking bad about him
are thinking bad about him or maybe they
were plotting against him you know ya
know I think and the psychiatrist said
that - they said one thing that he did
have probably was paranoid personality
disorder where he thought everyone was
out to get him or he was like talking
about he had to be that we get in order
to survive you had he was constantly
trying to put himself in the in the
place of the enemy and see things the
way the enemy saw things so if somebody
said something fishy he tried to put
himself in your position and try to see
himself through your eyes which would
really [ __ ] bother oh so this is what
you're thinking about me oh you think
that I'm doing it oh this is what you
think about me that's what he's sucking
doing yeah anyway I'll beat your ass for
even thinking that about me you know I
mean he how does he know what another
person is thinking you didn't think that
about him
yeah that's what he thinks he would
thank you reception right yeah and I
mean the same thing kind of happened
apparently while him and Barbara were
still dating like before they even got
married um you know he got like really
upset at her for whatever reason one
time and she wanted to break up and say
she wanted to go like you know date
other people and apparently they were in
a car together and he like pulled a
hunting knife from somewhere and like
stuck it like either in the back of her
neck or like the back like not all the
way in but like stuck it so enough that
it would bleed and basically said you
know if you ever leave me I'll kill your
entire family so she thought at this
point that she didn't really have a
choice you know what I mean and you you
know you have to think this is like the
early 60s - I feel like nowadays I don't
know I don't want to say nowadays like
women wouldn't put up with that [ __ ]
because some woman would but um I think
back then she was like well most of the
time he's okay
so maybe it'll be alright or maybe I'll
just try not to piss him off and then
maybe a little awareness wasn't as great
back that's true information and stuff
and I feel like a lot of like it was
almost like I don't know it's like it
was almost like accepted because like
I'm thought I'm thinking about like [ __ ]
my grandmother used to say you know what
I mean it was almost kind of like
accepted that it dudes we did that dudes
were dicks and that you could slap your
wife around and that's just what
happened and women were just supposed to
put up with it
because that's just how they did you
know what I mean I feel like there was a
lot more acceptance I mean from talking
to my grandmother and people of that
generation I think it was just that
generation and you know what I you know
I you know I think that's coming from I
think it's a post-war yeah that's
exactly what guys coming back from World
War two and they're pretty [ __ ] amped
up and they kind of resort to violence
first yes that's what they knew yeah so
insane I think it was I think I think a
lot of that wife-beating epidemic of the
60s was really
and as fifties and sixties was really a
thing a [ __ ] world war - I think so -
I think well yeah and because and like I
said it's not really around anymore so
is alcoholism those dudes drank
themselves to death yeah it's like I
think about how common that is yeah you
just that you hear about that like from
back then yeah you just don't see
alcoholics like you used to yeah you
really don't I mean you know yes there
are still alcoholics but it's the big
lemon nose [ __ ] walking around
and anymore
not really no that was now that I think
about it yeah when I was a little kid I
saw lots of them they're all dead now
they were old men yeah when I was a
little kid they had a nose like a damn
lemon with veins in it and all kinds of
my dudes like that yeah and they would
just stumble around they drank and they
drank you know and they were like older
than my dad yeah they're like my
grandfather's generation yeah and they
just drank themselves debt that's World
War two I do feel like that was probably
like a large factor and like I said I
think that was kind of like I think
that's why maybe domestic violence was
like maybe more accepted back then too
because it's like oh well the guys they
came back from the war and they were all
messed up and it's just like that's just
what happens and that's you just have to
deal with it yeah you know what I mean
you know any better yeah so so I feel
like you know yeah you can say well she
shouldn't marry them or yet this now but
probably more common by then it's more
cut one more common back then and - at
that point like what the dudes gonna
[ __ ] stab you and said hey if you
leave me I'm gonna kill your whole
family I mean I would take that
seriously if I were you yeah so she was
probably like afraid this is before he
was a hit man no I think yes although
this was before he was a paid hitman
Noga although according to him by the
time that he made
Barbara in 1961 he estimated that he had
already killed 65 people just who pissed
him off and whatnot so he already killed
the guy at the bar with a pool cue
instead an inch apparently because like
I said you know he killed he says that
he killed a bunch of people before that
just because because they made him mad
before he started getting paid for it
Jeremy no he I was always in the
impression he couldn't remember
everybody killed I don't think he could
because like I said I just a lot of
those numbers kind of I remember him
throwing out we're just kind of nebulous
I was like about this or maybe like yeah
it's like the first interview cuz like I
said the HBO interviews were kind of
like a few years apart like when was
from like the mid to late 90s one was
from 2001 and I think one was from 2004
something like that cuz I think he died
in 2006 I want to say um but so it
seemed like every time they interviewed
him like the it was a little bit got a
little bit higher because I think the
first one he just said oh maybe like a
hundred people you know I'm not really
sure and then the second and he's like
oh maybe more like 200 and then like the
third one he was more like more than 200
cuz some um he remembered he did yeah
just like remember he did one day oh I
forgot about that one
yeah like I said but I believed him
though yeah I don't look like I said
some of the [ __ ] I think is exaggerated
but I do think he probably killed a lot
of people and he got away with it yeah I
mean because like I said a lot of it had
to do with the time and the place
yeah he's doing this in a bad
neighborhood in a time where cameras
weren't everywhere yeah because I
remember they asked him they said could
you they said could you do this today
and they were asked him this about ten
years ago could you get away with it he
goes most of it I couldn't get away with
yes he says not nowadays because a lot
of the shizzy were just do in public
yeah he did he he said there's too many
cameras yeah yeah he was just like do it
in the [ __ ] Street in a bar why you
were sitting at a stoplight yeah but
could blow your head off with a shotgun
and he wrote a motor motorcycle right
yeah he did that as well yeah yeah and
they asked him about that and he said
well that was a contract hit I think
yeah um because he said he had a picture
of the guy but he's like I pulled up
next to in the car and he's like I
wasn't sure if it was the right guy like
I called yeah and he's like and he
turned his
and he said something like [ __ ] you and
then he's like no [ __ ] you and then he
shot he's like he had a sawed-off
shotgun and he's like um and his head
just but he just blew his head
completely off and they asked him how he
felt about that and he just said I was
just kind of surprised I didn't think it
was gonna blow his head completely off
let's like all he said like super calm
like that and like the psychiatrist like
well most people when they see something
really horrible like that like it
affects them in some way he's like no I
was just surprised I didn't expect you
to blow his head off that's like it
that's all he so he'd already killed a
bunch people for yeah he didn't really
give a [ __ ] well I don't know why they
were so amazed because guys that have
you know extensive combat records know
who killed but they're kind of like that
- yeah yeah I'm you know they were
walking down the [ __ ] path here and
the machine gun was set up and I [ __ ]
modem all down how do you think that was
my brother by 30 yeah you know you know
I think there comes a point where even a
normal person if you're put in a
situation like that you have to shut it
off yeah or you will go insane yeah you
know what I mean
well I think in I don't think I don't
think so or it just becomes routine yeah
well I think what happens is in terms of
[ __ ] the count the combat that I know
you know which is in infantry style
warfare it's the enemy yeah you know
what I mean
they would kill you yeah they saw you
and you're defending your friends yeah
and you're trying to keep the unit
together to achieve the mission yeah
yeah you killed thirty of them okay that
was a good day yeah you know mowed them
down yeah well yeah you know I know
you're rewarded for it right your
buddies are going to has a good job yeah
so you have kind of like societal backup
on it yeah you know I mean you don't
really feel guilty about it because they
would have done that to you and your
buddies yeah it's just part of the rules
and that might me that might be where
kuklinski was coming from too because
its culture that's gangsters and well
they would have done the same thing to
me yeah if the situation's were reversed
rights and he's getting respect through
through his friends and his
organizations that are other gangsters
yeah respect and fear so that's that's a
that's a reward yeah along with money so
because apparently he made quite a bit
and that enables you to deal with it a
lot better yeah you know because I mean
he him and his family like lived a
pretty like upper-middle class lifestyle
yeah you know what I mean
he got a lot of money for I'm sorry
dude's head but he was just like yeah
alright he's like I know his head off
okay
yeah so like I said Barbara as quoted as
saying pretty much that he was very you
know he's very kind of like bipolar type
of thing he's like you know most the
time he was really awesome and then but
sometimes he would just flip and he
weren't really sure when that would
happen they actually had three kids
together two daughters Marik and Kristen
and also a son named Wayne you know she
says stuff like he would buy the kids
like really expensive stuff it's like he
bought her like $12,000 raccoon coat
like bought diamonds and all this other
stuff took him to expensive restaurants
all the time took him to Disney World
every year it's like you know so he was
like kind of lavishing [ __ ] if they've
had a really nice house in the suburbs
in New Jersey he would have barbecues
for the neighborhood there the neighbors
every week and [ __ ] like now like
everyone just thought they were totally
normal
however when he was in one of his what
she called bad Ritchie moods she called
him good Ritchie and bad Ritchie so when
he was in one of his bad Mitch Ritchie
moods he would go he'd start like you
know breaking furniture throwing [ __ ] at
or he'd start beating the crap out of
her he broke her nose at least one time
you know McKee ever beat the kids but he
was kind of emotionally abusive toward
them now the daughter Merrick when she
got older she claimed once that when she
got in trouble he killed her dog in
front of her he also allegedly told her
that you know if I accidentally kill
your mom in a rage one day I'm gonna
have to kill all of you to like all the
kids because you know you know is yes so
he did absolutely allegedly he did tell
them that like according to them when
they got older um yes so there was that
whole thing also the daughter says that
and this kind of like feeds into and
makes me believe that probably he did
kill people just for like cutting him
off at traffic and show like that is
that his daughter did say that like
when they were in the car with him he
would get really really you have like
road rage you know what I mean like
somebody just did something really like
my some out I watched the dude I studied
this [ __ ] body language and
everything he's not insane no he's not
no I had I was not insane he's not like
one of these guys deco I would kill my
whole family and it doesn't affect me he
just had a lot of control over his
emotions when when he's asked a
difficult question you can see him
gritting his teeth and trying to swallow
it and control his feelings and then he
gives you an answer yeah he is not he's
not a psychopath or sociopath where he
doesn't feel emotion he does feel it
yeah I think he's emotionally volatile
yes that he controls it yeah no because
he did a couple of times during the
interviews he would did you almost made
me mad and yeah okay that's it the
psychiatrist yet he almost wanted to
kill that guy yeah wanted to kill that
guy he choked it back and stopped and he
goes you almost made me mad yeah and and
he did get kind of emotional one time
when I was talking about his family the
only thing he ever regretted was abusing
his wife yeah and hurting his family but
although one thing that he did say and I
found this very interesting is that you
know he said that he was sorry about it
and then he wished his family would
forgive him but then he said he's like
well I couldn't have been that sorry
because I kept doing it yeah he said
that I understand was doing so he had
that much insight about it yeah well
he's intelligent guy yeah he just knew
that it was he had pathological behavior
yeah that he was just relentless it was
a head and do what I believe his early
childhood this is just what he was yeah
and he had a bunch of weird conflicts
that kept rising
but that conflict is what fueled his
career as a professional killer
yeah that's where the money was coming
from oh yeah and doing it kept that ball
rolling as long as he was killing people
he was gonna be volatile like that yeah
yeah I just there was just no way out of
it yeah and he wanted to have a family
but he just can't be a family man a real
family man
doing that kind of [ __ ] yeah because
that's what I was like that
one of the things that I was kind of
curious about when I was watching that
interview like watching him talk about
his family because he did get he did
tear up and he did choke up when he was
talking about his family and how he
didn't think they would forgive him and
he wanted them to and he did say he
choked up - when he said that he would
have done anything for his children that
he's like if I had to kill this whole
roomful of you for them then I would do
that you know what I mean but it's
really strange because I always wondered
it's like at this point in his life was
he even capable of loving anyone I think
so
I don't know I think so it was hard for
me - I think so just I just think he had
a lot of demons that were driving him
and that and that was his job and it was
it took over him yeah there's a lot of
[ __ ] and techniques and tactics that he
uses I don't know if you're gonna get in
to him or not yeah but he talks about
him in detail in his interviews yeah
about if you're gonna kill a target best
thing to do is to freeze it yeah and
then that way which that's why they call
them that the Iceman
that's where you and I'll get into that
guy you get into it later yeah you
freeze it it helps you hide time and
death well it would if he didn't mess it
up like he didn't [ __ ] it well he got he
in a way got very lazy because this
became a mass production type job yeah
he did this [ __ ] regularly yeah and he
kind of lose track and it became routine
which that's how he got [ __ ] caught
is that he just stopped taking it
seriously yeah I think he just got
sloppy yeah oh he just didn't think he
could get caught for killing people well
he didn't get caught for really yes so
just like I guess you just kind of got
like whatever yeah [ __ ] it
yes what he's doing now apparently
according to I read an interview with
Barbara but I think was in the Guardian
or something like that now she said that
when their young daughter Kristin was a
little bit older that her and Kristin
often plotted they were actually gonna
poison him they plotted it for like a
really long time but they never like
quite had the balls to do it they said
well one thing was that he would always
and I don't know if he did this because
he says bad
that his family 100 a poison him but he
would like feed like parts of his food
to like their dog and he didn't want to
kill they don't want to kill the dog
obviously so they were kind of like
afraid that that went out because they
were afraid I guess they were afraid
that he suspected so they never did do
it but she did say later on she's like I
wished him dead every single day yeah
even though from the outside they looked
like the perfect family they said look
Kuklinski was like he was like an usher
like at the church it's like they had
[ __ ] barbecues for their neighbors
every week he just seemed like a normal
dude now Barbara did say she's like I
never asked him and this was probably
another thing from the 60s she never
really asked him like what his business
was she just thought he was a
businessman she says that she suspected
that maybe it was illegally denied
espect that he was killing people for
money but she did suspect that maybe he
was doing some illegal [ __ ] but she's
like she never asked him she's like look
he'd get up in the middle of dinner he'd
get up in the middle of the night and
say you know I have to go to work and he
would leave she's like I never asked him
where he was going and he never told me
and another thing that kuklinski did to
it was apparently you know once he got
involved you know with various you know
crime families he would never tell any
of his associates where he lived he
would never tell them anything about his
family he wanted to keep everything
compartmentalized and he even said that
a lot of his interviews he's like look I
never wanted any of them at my house I
didn't want my family and my work life
to be you know combined he wanted to be
like family guy over here contract
killer over here he didn't want any
crossing over he's like none no gangs
gangsters or anything like that ever
came to my house or to my neighborhood
or nothing they didn't even know where
he lived yeah and the weird thing about
the guys he wasn't really a part of any
kind of family no he was a freelance
freelance guy and different
organizations would hire him to do it
yeah and you know that he would did it
for small-time guys and I think mostly
small-time in middle middle-ranking yeah
I mean pretty much anyone that would
give him any money why did you do and
say hey whack this guy he'd be like all
right and he he ended up collecting some
interesting [ __ ] friends a trained
and one was an ice cream truck guy I
don't if you're gonna get into this yeah
thing from God mr. Softee in mr. frizzy
but his mystery it's hard to believe
that a guy like mr. softy existed yeah
but I guess he did yeah it was a real
guy he was a serial killer that lived
out that worked out of an ice cream
truck and poisoned the people's dads
basically he was like a mad scientist
mad science typing character Boyson he
learned everything about poisons from
this guy different ways to kill people
would she you tell stories about this
ice cream truck the rive driver yeah
that's a weird [ __ ] tale like I said
now if you guys haven't seen there is a
movie that came out in 2012 with Michael
Shannon in at playing kuklinski and it's
called the Ice Man and it's actually
really good even though some of it it's
fairly accurate but some of its kind of
exaggerated and some of it's they don't
know if it's really happen or not but
they kind of go into the mr. Softee
thing although in the movie he's called
mr. frizzy and he hung out with him for
I think at least a year it was a while
and but I think he killed him maybe a
Lisa or somebody killed him but he said
you know they said well what happened to
goes well more I found out about the guy
who I rose I couldn't let him live they
killed him yeah he learned everything
every he learned all the guy's knowledge
and then killed it yeah yeah so yeah so
no wasn't anything why that guy running
around yeah well like I said he said
later on like in the prison interview he
said I killed pretty much all he killed
all of his parents except one and that
was the one that ended up indirectly
getting him arrested
so you know we'll get that later but
yeah so like I said his wife said that
she never like asked him where the money
was coming from because it you know the
money was good pretty good and
everything an interesting thing about
kuklinski though is that unlike a lot of
the other gangsters he didn't really
have any of the same vices that they had
like has a lot of other gangsters you
know they were on drugs or they were
drunk so there were you know
womanisers gamblers he did like to
gamble but that was about it like he
didn't really drink he didn't take drugs
he didn't like go run around cheating on
his wife or anything like that you
didn't do anything like that he was like
kind of straight arrow which was a
little strange in that
area so um what where are we at all
right so we're almost at an hour so
let's take a break now and when we come
back we will start talking about all of
his criminal activities yeah so I gotta
make a drink we'll get into the fun
stuff oh my goodness your drinks and
today you're almost empty already all
right so we're gonna take a break now we
will be back in just a people hey buddy
what's he doing what's he doing yeah
just chillin yeah look at this little
belly oh she's very sensitive about that
you resent to him about that it's cute
or not making fun I promise
you're mad though could look at your
little tail look good dude yeah oh
goodness oh my goodness you're just
gonna lay there at the entrance to
mommy's office yeah mommy's home alone
anyone to pick up the car yeah Morgan I
ain't Pookie why are you mad why you
meant you look like you're mad yeah
and my harsh in your buzz harsh in your
mellow okay oh yeah you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
baby's case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
all right we're back
Tom has refreshed his drink refreshed
that one is a different one today what
I'm doing is I got silver tequila in
there yeah
citrus flavored Red Bull and some and
some lime juice oh wait is that a thing
or do you have a name of thing yesterday
they gave me up and rose up in Tampa oh
that's right all about that so I do this
one too so you're making that one at
home now that's right you had to go by
the we had to go by the yellow tropical
red ball just for that yeah
cuz you wanted to replicate it at home
yeah alright so talking about richard
kuklinski now weird we've kind of went
into like his personal life his past as
[ __ ] like that so now we're gonna talk
about his criminal history yeah now
according to him and like I said yes I'm
sure he kills a lot of people some of
the [ __ ] he said you probably I should
take with a grain of salt cuz I think he
did have a tendency to exaggerate weight
grandstanding right so you know I don't
know how much of this is true or not
according to him the first murder that
he committed happened in 1948 or 1949 he
was 13 or 14 years old apparently there
was this kid who was his age or maybe a
little bit older named Charlie Lane who
he was kind of like the head of this
neighborhood gang they were called the
project boys you know they lived in the
same neighborhood as him and they were
always like picking on him cuz I guess
like I said when he was young he was
like really small and he had kind of
like you know sticky-outy ears and why
not so I guess they kind of picked on
him so he had been bullied and he was
getting beat up by these kids all the
time so at one point he just decided he
wasn't gonna take it anymore and he
actually took now I've heard different
sources say either a thick like a big
wooden dowel or that he took like the
steel rod out of the closet you know
like the [ __ ] you hang everything on but
he took that out and then he went and
found this kid and just started beating
the [ __ ] out of him
now according to him he didn't intend to
kill this boy but that he beat him so
much that he just killed him and then he
was just like laying there not move
he's like oh [ __ ] I killed him now he
said later on that he felt bad about it
at first you know he was only 13 or 14
years old at the time um but that later
on he kind of came to terms with it he
was just like okay well I guess that's
just how it goes you know what I mean
yeah well I see when you make that jump
you lost that line and it's such an
early age you adapt to it a lot faster
yeah you're like company like me but
tell your fifteen was like I was a long
time ago I'd killed that dude yeah yeah
hurry and [ __ ] they have two years I was
new so you're able to just kind of
incorporate it and it from here like
you're like oh yeah yeah people kill
each other and that's how it goes that's
yeah you know you get what you asked for
you know that's kind of like I said he
probably thought I mean in his 13 14
year-old mind he thought well these kids
have been picking on me all the time so
he had it coming yeah um and and he said
later I don't know if this is true or
not but he did say yeah I didn't really
intend to kill him
but I just started beating him and beat
him and he just died um now earlier on
he I think he said originally that he
beat the kid to death when he realized
the kid was dead he just like left him
in the woods somewhere later on in a
later interview he actually said no I
took the kids body I cut off his
fingertips with a hatchet and then I
pulled his teeth out like with pliers I
would assume so he wouldn't be
identified then I threw him off a bridge
in South Jersey um I'm not sure if
that's true or it that was just like a
later exaggeration I had a 13 year old
boy that's what I'm saying it's like
where how did he get the kid like how
far away was this bridge everybody's
taking this kid to do what he put him in
a wagon or something yeah and then like
he pulled his teeth out and cut his
fingers off I don't know if that's true
or not I'm not debating whether he
killed the kid maybe he did but I'm just
saying I think at first he just said
yeah I beat him to death and then I just
like left him in the woods somewhere now
they've never found this kid's body as
far as I know so I so I don't know this
could be [ __ ] it could be [ __ ]
it was a rough area yeah
from an earlier era yeah maybe you could
get away with it but you think they
would have found that body yeah you
would think that well like I said you
think I'm wearing putting that parents
would have went looking formal I think
he he said at first I think he said he
dumped him in the Pine Barrens which you
know that's a big I would an area would
get him down there in his car [ __ ]
don't have that's what's he gonna do put
him in a duffle bag and carry him I have
a hard time seeing a 13 year old boy
pulling that off to me I think it'd be
more likely to 13 year old boy would
kill another kid by accident just leave
him right there and that's kind of what
I think I mean just kind of trying to
cast back to myself when I was 13 or 14
not that I would have done something
Raja's that pulled him off the road and
[ __ ] covered him up with some
branches and run yeah and just be like
[ __ ] there's nothing to do with me by
yeah that's kind of what I feel like
probably which minute of the body would
have been found it might be a [ __ ]
story maybe but I'm just saying this is
usually credited as as first murder that
he said remember the kid now there's
another situation there's another
situation to consider this is a pretty
[ __ ] rough area a lot of times a lot
of times the the reason why bodies are
found is because there's a family that's
causing the police to look for the
public for the body brain mod abandoned
the kid [ __ ] was an [ __ ] and from
a [ __ ] bad family himself and when
the kid didn't show up the parents
always like I [ __ ] whatever he ran
right ran away because that does happen
right and and then they don't care that
he ran away then the couple breaks up
one of them gets killed or dies doing
this the other one gets it you know what
I mean so yeah it's possible that family
might have dissolved maybe it had bit
already been dissolved by the time that
the kid was killed
yeah and like I said even if he did take
the body like maybe he killed the kid
like in kind of a remote area and then
he just like left him in the woods and
no one thought to look for him it'd be
that way to the family wasn't family
wasn't asking the cops to look for him
right cuz like I said it's sad but that
does happen it happens a lot yeah
I've written about you you know is I
think I think you know the average
person would think that you know the man
that you kill somebody there's an
immediate search for that person not
always oh no not always depends who it
is
sir all depends on who it is who the
family is is is there a family that's
worrying about you because you didn't
come back yeah and if there isn't a
family worried about you
they look for you well that's what I
mean and this and I was just telling you
this the other day it's like when I was
researching my books you would be
appalled at how many unidentified bodies
there are found and there are never
identified like these are people that
have never been reported missing yes
because either because they don't have
families or their families don't give a
[ __ ] about them or their families are
dead or they just move to a different
state or they you know or there's an any
number of reasons a lot of times the
problem is is that the victim was a pain
in the ass the family's glad that that
person is out of their [ __ ] hair they
don't know that the person is dead but
they also don't care where that person
is as long as they're not [ __ ] taking
up space yeah in their house and then
that family itself might be you know
like I said kind of dissolving yeah you
know the husband or the mother and
father going different ways or maybe
there was only a single mother and she's
kind of elderly she didn't give a [ __ ]
she's only got a few years left to live
anyway that kind of [ __ ] she's on
[ __ ] welfare so you know they just
said ah she's that girl's gone [ __ ]
you know yeah she's off living yeah yeah
she doing all those drugs I don't want
her around here she needs to shape up
you know well that little little does
that you know little does she know that
her daughter got killed in a truck stop
[ __ ] ten years ago she's even [ __ ]
know yeah I'm like I said they might
never identify them like they somebody
finds the body and like that's like I
said there's thousands and thousands and
thousands a lot of kids just leave yeah
and a lot of them are kids or teenagers
yeah they just leave home and are never
seen again the parents don't really give
a [ __ ] well and I suspect what if there
are little little kids
I suspect that their parents probably
killed them and then dump them somewhere
and that's the reason why no one's
looking another thing to you because
they don't report them because they're
the ones that did it
yeah parents killed their kids and but
sometimes and you never reported me
looked it happened in this case cuckoo
olenski's dad yep killed his older
brother and I just said oh he fell down
the stairs if you're not really
well-known family you can kill your own
children nobody come
about it nobody knows that's what I like
scary but it's true yeah it's true we've
seen it right there in the system yeah
so yeah so apparently after he killed
Charlie Lane who was like the head of
this gang he decided that he was gonna
go after the other boys in the gang also
now he gets like this
he finds them he gets like this metal
pole like I'd have a trash can or
whatever and beat all of them he didn't
kill any of them but he built beat all
of them like almost to death um now he
said that this was like like I said I
don't know if this actually happened or
not but he said that this was kind of
like a turning point in his life because
this was a point where he realized what
he said the quote was oh it's better to
give than receive yeah in the sense that
better to do understand it's better to
just like beat the [ __ ] out of somebody
that I'd rather than let them bully you
and that like it gave him power like
violence gave him power and that was
like the first time that he realized it
goes back to what I said before
yeah now at this stage it's like I said
he became kind of like through his
teenage years he kind of became somebody
that was known for having like a
hair-trigger temper and pretty much
anything you said that pissed him off or
made him feel bad or anything like that
he would beat the [ __ ] out of you or
kill you for it and he kind of had a
little bit of a reputation for doing
that um so he does he started out
actually not as a you know contract
killer but he started out kind of like
as a pool shark um and when he was doing
that like he also kind of got a
reputation of having like a really bad
temper and like you know don't [ __ ] with
him or you know he'll kill you and
Schilling yeah this is his first string
of [ __ ] homicides that interested me
don't want the ones that around that
damn pool yeah you could get into any of
those um well not so much because there
was they don't know a lot about that
like I said pretty much only his it's
only his word you know what I mean cuz
from what I remember the first one he
did as as what he considered to be an
adult kill so in that pool hall he got
into a fight and I think he killed one
of them with a damn pool cue yeah
in a fight right there in the pool hall
he said he did yeah said he killed the
guy although he never got arrested or
even questioned about that one yeah I
wonder if that actually happened see you
like I said it's hard to say um because
you have to understand not only one you
know he probably exaggerated some of the
[ __ ] but also to the kind of people he
was hanging out with were all criminals
they wouldn't gone to the police so they
wouldn't have gone to the police so it's
like if someone was like in some like
criminal hangout bar and somebody beat
the [ __ ] up send they died
nobody's gonna report that yeah you know
I mean other one I remembered he he
talked about it was around that pool
hall somebody was talking [ __ ] one of
these guys are real [ __ ] he considered
himself be real tough God was [ __ ]
with him and talking all this [ __ ] and
kuklinski was walking out walking out of
the pool hall and saw him down in the
back alley behind the pool hall taking a
piss he walked up behind that guy and he
had to garrote a girl yeah and put it
around his [ __ ] neck while the guy
was taking a piss and turned around
backwards and then leaned yeah I
remember him saying that hung him over
his shoulder yeah and just sit there and
let him take a piss off his back of his
shoulder while he strangled to death
yeah and then I said there he stood
there for a long time til the guy was
dead just dropped him and then walked
off like nothing ever happened
yeah I'm dead net damn I remember very
plausible I remember him saying that he
sent that to the psychiatrist one of the
interviews that I was watching the other
day and he said well the first thing he
said before he described just what you
said he said oh you know I strangled the
guy in kind of her original ways like
her maybe its original I don't really
know and then he said what you just said
the how he got that wake over his
shoulder and then he said and I felt the
guy die like I felt him go limp and then
the psychiatrist asked well how did you
feel about that and he's like I didn't
really feel any way about it yes I just
felt him die that's that's like all he
said you know what I mean it's like I
kind of feel like uh you know the
psychiatrist was trying to like you know
kind of emotion trying to get a bead on
him or trying to get a read on so he
kept asking him like you know how did
you feel
this how did you feel about that and
it's almost kind of like kuklinski
didn't really I'm not saying not that he
didn't understand the question but I
think he was kind of getting annoyed
that he kept asking him that because he
didn't feel anything well he said he
didn't feel he said early said he didn't
I don't believe that was the case I
believe he felt [ __ ] pleasure
gratification from it now he did say
[ __ ] this dude say that killing was the
well they okay now the psychiatrist did
ask him at one point is like what brings
you pleasure the only thing he said was
sex he said that was the only thing that
like God is adrenaline going or anything
like that and they said just killing
people bring you pleasure and he's like
not really he's like he said it's more
like satisfaction like he could relax
after it happened because you know his
problem has been eliminated and I guess
is kind of what he was getting at so he
almost didn't say that it caused him any
pleasure but almost she was like a
relief that's what I got out I got out
of it is that he got satisfaction from
it that it was another bad guy gone yeah
is really you know I mean you can look
at kuklinski as a [ __ ] villain but
he's killing other gangsters and other
[ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] from his point
of view he thought he saw himself as the
good guy killing evil he probably did
even though he killed allegedly he
killed random people too just yeah and
people in the street right I heard them
stories and I think that what that was
there's kind of like experimentation
yeah he did that as well like he was
curious to see what things would work me
I'm gonna see if it works on this guy
and see if I can use that against these
other bad guys
mm-hm so he was just kind of
dispassionate about it nothing yeah
that's a good word that's exactly what
it was just to see if the technique
worked it didn't anything to do with the
victim yeah it didn't have like like I
said he said at one point that he was
curious to see if a crossbow would kill
somebody ya know like I said I don't
know if this really happened or not but
this is something that he said he said I
was curious to see if a crossbow would
kill somebody and how it would work and
everything like that so I had one and
he's like so I was in a car and I was
pulled over to curb so I just like
motion to random dude over to the car
like I was gonna ask for directions and
then I just shot him in the head
yeah well it made sense because he
didn't want to try it on a dangerous guy
who might turn around [ __ ] shoot him
yeah or do it on a job or he might where
he not might miss the kill and not get
paid that kind of deal so he tried it on
a guinea pig yeah just on a random
person yeah
and the psychiatrist asked him he's like
will did it working is like oh yeah he's
like it went half way into his head just
like yeah just like that he said it just
like that didn't that something right so
yeah
Bobo's funny is that he's talking about
all these people that he killed and in a
lot of cases the cops didn't know the
homicide that he was talking about yeah
there's not a lot of corroboration yeah
but like I guess though is that records
have [ __ ] in that area during that time
around New York police work was pretty
damn [ __ ] shoddy that's why it's kind
of ambiguous and I think a lot of that
did happen oh yeah I'm not denying this
is some of the homicides I'm sure it is
some of the homicides they knew about
exactly yeah oh yeah we know about that
one so yeah I'm not saying like a lot of
these didn't happen I did I do think he
exaggerated somewhat but I'm not saying
that I don't think that he did like a
hundred people okay I don't doubt that
I mean think I don't think he knows how
many he killed I don't think so well he
doesn't know they just asked him and
he's like I don't know maybe a hundred
two hundred he doesn't really need he
also had he also had like a private well
or like a secret place it was like a
cave where he would take guys victims
and [ __ ] have him eaten to death by
rats and he'd film it so he said
although they've never although they've
never found the tape they never find the
cave though they have those caves but
the thing about it is that because
that's a pretty popular claim that he
would kind of tie up guys or he would
like cut them so they would bleed and
then he would put them in these caves in
Philadelphia and that camera and then
the camera and then like the rats would
eat them but other people that because
those caves where he said that he left
them are like pretty popular like the
tourists and stuff and they're like one
we've never found any human remains
there and to the tapes I've never been
found and three a lot of the people that
you know frequent those caves like you
know tour guides and stuff like that
they said you know there are rats in
these caves but they don't think that
they would you know that they wouldn't
act the way that he yeah this I'm not
saying it's not true but a lot of people
have thought that this claim was
probably one of he was bullshitting
about the ice cream man
I don't well that was a real guy and
that guy did turn up dead in his [ __ ]
truck and everything yeah so all of that
that's it happen but like I said it's
it's hard to say because he was a
horrible person and they know for sure
that he did several murders right but it
you know it's ambiguous because it's
kind of like him you know when we were
talking about Henry Lee Lucas on the
[ __ ] when we were talking about the
confession killer like on the matinee
show yeah where it's like [ __ ] a lot
though yeah but it's like he did kill
people he did yeah but did he kill 600
people no obviously not okay so yeah I
think it was three yeah but uh you know
I think he killed his mom and those
other two but yeah so it's the same
situation here did this guy kill a lot
of people yes did he kill 300 people I
don't know maybe maybe it's not
impossible I think he did kid he did
tell a story that some teenagers in a
van tried to run him off the road when
he was going through one of the through
a mountainous road and then he caught
back up to him drove them off the road
gunned him down killed him and they did
find those guys yeah he said yeah I
remember him saying about that he
couldn't remember how many of them there
were I think it was three or four of
them yeah he just he just said didn't
think as the psychiatrist or whoever you
asked how many were there he's like I
don't know a bunch of them I think that
did get verify that they did find those
guys all down [ __ ] off the side of
the road their van down there yeah maybe
like I said a lot of a lot of the [ __ ]
that he said a lot of [ __ ] that he said
there's not like corroboration you know
what I mean so I don't know I'm not
saying that he didn't kill a lot of
people cuz I'm sure he probably did but
some of the stuff might have been like
later exaggeration like he was trying to
sound like a bad like about us you know
I mean because he needed like more
people what about his what about his
gangster hideout where he
take all the bodies and cut him into
pieces and freeze well now that existed
didn't it that was um they're not sure
where he would put the body they only
know of one that he froze because they
found it and with you he didn't do it
right
um there was like a couple of
documentaries I saw uh said that there
was this place in New Jersey and it was
called the store and it wasn't just him
it was like a mob place where you would
take the bodies and cut them up they
would like put them you know what I mean
did that exist probably um but you know
what I mean I so they they're not really
sure the one body that they found that
they know that he froze they're not sure
where he kept that because it was there
for two years they said it must been an
industrial freezer or it was in mr.
stoppies truck or something but they're
not sure where that was you know I mean
because they don't know they just found
the body when it was dumped okay so they
don't know where he kept it they know
that he kept it somewhere for a couple
years and it was frozen but they don't
know where okay as far as I know nobody
knows where he kept all right let's go
through the timeline again we're
probably losing the audio so apparently
what he started doing in about 1954 is
he starts going around New York um just
kind of like looking for people to kill
for various reasons and like I said I
think this was kind of like before he
even had any contracts this was kind of
it seems like it was in his experimental
phase now I don't think as far as I know
he never killed any women and he he
later said that he would never kill a
child and that he's like I probably
never would have killed he's like I
wouldn't have killed a woman but any man
if you told him to kill this dude that
dude just kill that guy walking to the
street he'd be like all right and he
would do it he wasn't bothered about it
um so he said during this period where
he wasn't getting paid for it he was
just killing people that you know pissed
him off or he was just a small-time
criminal at this point or who stiffed
him you know out of money or just you
know did something to annoy him so he
would you know either shoot them he
would stab them blood
he said that he dumped some in the
Hudson River which I guess a lot of
mobsters did that ever dredged the
[ __ ] Hudson River it was what our
many bodies are gonna find because
remember we were watching
um we were watching the Irishmen the
other day and there was a whole scene
where he was just like throwing all the
guns but I don't I don't remember if it
was the Hudson River but he was Turley
they shared the bottom just like Oh God
because that's real like all the mobs
like I don't know why they don't know
why they did that because ballistics
aren't what they thought it was yeah you
know I mean it's very difficult to match
a bullet to a gun rifling marks are
constantly changing on those things
every time you [ __ ] fire a bullet
down that was some that was some [ __ ]
legal courtroom hocus-pocus to try to
get that [ __ ] to match up yeah
you know there's no reason to destroy
God after that after that well just to
be on the safe side I would yes well you
don't want to be caught in in possession
of the damn thing yeah but you would
think that you could have a place to
hide it and let it cool off so funniest
[ __ ] thing there I saw a damn British
program where it was all [ __ ] around
like a group of two guns that went out
dude they were tracking the activity
criminal activity of of to any was to me
one or two firearms that were in England
and how many people is shot that got
shot in England with those two guns just
those two guns and there was just
getting passed from hand to hand yeah
they're in zyk [ __ ] investigation of
how many people were killed by his two
guns at me as elses Americans just
laughing we got millions of those
[ __ ] pegs over here and the British
are [ __ ] worried about two guns
yeah but if they killed a lot of people
I mean yeah well it's because they don't
have any guns yes well that way that
those few guns are being filtered only
through the hands of criminals yeah you
know [ __ ] over here we have I think
we have more than two million just
ak-47s alone yeah most of them nuttin
you know it's that's like the least
likely type of firearm to be used in a
crime most most common firearms to be
used in a crime or like little 25s and
22s and 380s little tiny subcompact well
easier to see something you can see on
hide or what those
Oh rifles and those assault rifles it
just [ __ ] very rare than anybody uses
anything like oh yeah you can't like a
[ __ ] walk down the street with no
[ __ ] everybody would see coming yeah I
can't [ __ ] hide it under anything and
he said well what about those school
shootings
yeah those school shoot mostly double
9-millimeter pistols if you actually go
through there and see how many shootings
happen in schools of 9-millimeter
pistols and only like one or two people
and because any [ __ ] any [ __ ] kid
that takes a gun to school shoot some
kids is because they're [ __ ] bullying
him and he's a [ __ ] dork and he
shoots somebody [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
with him well like I said never really
hear about it because it's maybe only
one or two people killed well that's
kind of what happened in Kuklinski's
case I knew when he was a little kid
apparently got bullied a lot yeah and he
just he didn't have that great of a home
life it's I'm sure a lot of people in
that neighborhood did not yeah
don't bully people yes the King I mean
you never NIT welcome we'll see now
that's kind of like the whole and if
everybody would just do this yeah the
world to be much better place don't [ __ ]
it well just leave people the [ __ ]
[ __ ] alone and you won't get shot leave
people the [ __ ] I don't care what just
let him do their [ __ ] yeah
leave him alone you've had nothing to do
with you that's nothing to do with now
just let him [ __ ] live their life the
way they want to [ __ ] live it and
just keep your [ __ ] [ __ ] out of it
just keep out of it right easy
all right so apparently according to
most sources I read Kuklinski's going
around
various parts of Manhattan experimenting
like figuring out just killing random
people and whatnot but he was always
using different methods so that from
several things that I read apparently
the cops did not know that this was all
one person so they thought it was the
famous like I think he mentioned this a
few episodes ago bomb on bomb violence
they thought it was homeless people
killing each other yeah because it was
all different like some of the people
were bludgeoned some were shot some were
stabbed you know there were all these
different like methods of murder so they
didn't like put them all together as
being like one guy well
the basics of police investigation I
knew about patterns he just knew that
you didn't want to leave a pattern yeah
make it different each time and they
would yeah and he basically said that
outright right now
he um in a later interview when they
were kind of asking him about what did
you get out of this like you know what
did you get out of killing people um he
didn't really he said the killing was
kind of like he said the killing for me
was secondary that was a quote he
enjoyed the hunt he enjoyed the
challenge like how he was going to kill
this person to not get caught um he's
like for him the killing was just kind
of like that was like the end of it
routine but it's like he kind of got
more of a charge out of figuring
everything out beforehand how he was
gonna do it he was mission oriented he
was yeah yeah um so you know that was a
very and like according to one writer
that actually wrote a biography of him
later on he thought that maybe
Kuklinski was bipolar but he had never
like taken any medication obviously or
he'd never been to a psychiatrist or
anything like that because he said that
the writer said he's like because he had
interviewed him at length and he's like
admitting that something was wrong with
him was not something he would ever do
you know what I mean
yeah so he would never like this point
of view is get help or anything like
that his point of view it was normal
yeah I mean he knew he was unusual he
did know because I gave is special like
I said later on when the psychiatrist
interviewed him when he was in prison
like shortly you know probably a couple
of years before he died he did seem to
realize that he was unusual you know
what I mean and he was interested like
he was happy that the psychiatrist came
because apparently I mean he had talked
to some other psychiatrists by this time
but he hadn't talked to them to such an
extent like he was very curious about
what the psychiatrist would say about
him and even when I thought this was
very interesting the psychiatrist at one
point whose name is Park Dietz by the
way he's you know he's on a like a lot
of the lecture crime shows if you seem
like a bunch of true crime shows you
will have seen him before he's very
familiar
so he asked you know Kuklinski at one
point he's like I'm gonna turn the
tables and I'm gonna ask you like if you
have any questions for me like do you
want to ask anything about me so
Kuklinski pauses for a long time but
then interestingly instead of asking
about the psychiatrist he asks what does
the psychiatrist think about him which I
thought was very interesting like that
was kind of like all he could think of
was himself right so it's like he wasn't
curious about the psychiatrist he wasn't
curious about cuz I thought he want to
ask something like why'd you want to
become a psychiatrist or why did you
desert or something like that but he
didn't he's like he just asked us i
casual what do you think about me right
that's what he asked why would you be
curious about a psychiatrist i because i
from this point of view that's just a
mundane regular person yeah you know
Kuklinski sees himself as I'm the
[ __ ] real deal I was like I'm doing
[ __ ] you guys make movies about I'm a
celebrity yeah they definitely did seem
he wasn't I you know he wasn't as self
aggrandizing not as obviously self
aggrandizing as some other serial
killers he was but he had a more
realistic view of himself but he did
have he had a little bit of that he did
have a little bit of pumping himself up
to kind of like look more about he knew
he was a badass yeah he knew but yeah
but for in his case it wasn't [ __ ] I
mean he did do a lot of that show yeah
you know I mean he just maybe kind of
like put a little bit of icing on it
yeah I think so
okay so by about the mid-1960s and they
showed this in the Iceman movie he
starts working at this film lab in
Manhattan now this film lab apparently
they processed copies of like kind of a
lot of major films like Disney movies
and all that other kind of stuff so he
started making like bootleg copies of
them not only for his own family but
also to kind of you know sell to other
people you know in the black market
also discovered there was like a really
big black market in bootleg porno so he
started making that too and that was
kind of like a big source of income like
in the beginning of his criminal career
is he
making these like knockoff copies when
he was in the lab and he was like
selling them on the black market right
now he was copying the porn and selling
copies of porn yes
so he wasn't producing his own no copy
and other people yeah he was he was like
I said he worked in a film lab he was
getting like big-budget like Hollywood
moves like Disney movies like cartoons
and [ __ ] like that - he made bootlegs of
that - but um and made some money off
that but he made more money off porn
right like just kind of selling it on
the black market now it was in this
particular film lab and through his
bootlegging work and whatnot that he
kind of started to get into you know a
little bit of like minor gang activity
he kind of got into you know pornography
track trafficking drug trafficking um he
got like a couple of guys and he started
like kind of a burglary ring mostly
stealing cars Corvettes
he specialized in apparently the only
crime that he was ever arrested for like
before he later got arrested for the
murder for murders was passing a bad
chick that's it and they let him off
after he said that he would pay the
amount you know I mean he said he'd pay
it and then they let him care that was
the only [ __ ] crime that he was ever
[ __ ] even though he was doing all this
[ __ ] okay so apparently and like I said
there is some you know there's a little
bit of controversy about this but
apparently he met this guy named Roy
DeMeo he was he would later kind of be a
higher-up in the Gambino crime family he
apparently met this guy he had borrowed
money from a loanshark
this loan shark was kind of like a mob
connected guy
Kuklinski apparently missed a payment
Roy DeMeo and two other guys came and
beat the [ __ ] out of him to get the
money because he hadn't paid and
according to like I said according to
Kuklinski's story the guys were so
impressed that he just kind of like took
the beating and he didn't cry or
anything you know he didn't like beg beg
for anything he just kind of like took
it like a
in and that kind of impressed them so
apparently Roy DeMeo was so impressed by
that that he later started throwing some
jobs to kuklinski you know if somebody
needed beating up because they hadn't
paid or if somebody needed to be whacked
or something like that so he starts like
kind of giving him these little jobs now
so the story goes his kind of like you
know his whole start on this mob thing
was DeMaio took him out in a car and
said so they just Park on this random
city street DeMaio says okay well if I
just told you to kill a guy and you
don't know who it was or anything like
that would you do it
and kuklinski said yeah I could probably
do that so they go out there and he's
like okay well see that guy walking a
dog over there go kill that guy so
Kuklinski apparently just gets out of
the car and he said in the interview he
said yeah I just walked past this guy's
just a dude walking his dog like a
normal dude and he just kind of walked
past him like that and then he just shot
him in the head then he got back in the
car and they left it was his audition to
see if he could yeah dude cool that's
apparently what that was so evidently
after that happened and like I said
there is some controversy about this but
evidently after that happened Roy DeMeo
said okay well you're gonna be the go-to
guy for like any hits we have to do
because apparently you don't give a [ __ ]
and you'll just do whatever you're told
and you don't like now that homicide did
is that verified by the police see this
is the problem because okay some people
that had written like a couple of guys
that wrote a book about the Roy DeMeo
crew later on there was a book written
about them it was called murder machine
in that book
Kuklinski is not mentioned hmm okay now
Albert DeMaio who was Roy DeMeo his son
also wrote a book about his dad called
for the sins of my father that book also
does not mention kuklinski so I don't
know I'm not saying the two guys didn't
know each other and that this [ __ ]
didn't happen but I'm just saying that
if they did apparently the Gambino crime
family are not saying that they know him
or he was very minor or because like I
said Kuklinski wasn't in the mob he
wasn't like in any of the crime families
yeah he was a contract killer who you
know if you needed somebody whacked and
you gave him the money like he would do
it like he wasn't in any of the crews or
anything like that although you know
from my understanding most of those
families did that [ __ ] with their own
people that they trusted they didn't
really like chances are they wouldn't go
outside their own family to get that
[ __ ] done but maybe that's what I'm
saying it's like I'm not saying either
way I don't know I wasn't there
now there's a chance that he
bullshitting about that amazing I'm just
saying now later on too Kuklinski said
that he killed DeMaio
now DeMaio was murdered he was found in
the trunk of his car in 1983 however
most people in the know like people that
you know were undercover agents or other
people in the crime file it later
flipped and stuff like that said that
DeMaio was probably killed by members of
his own crew yeah and not by kuklinski
although kuklinski later did claimed to
have killed him but he could have read
about that and then said that he did it
perhaps so it could be that kuklinski
maybe wanted to write himself into mob
history that's kind of what I'm
suspecting like I'm like I said I don't
I'm not saying that he didn't kill a
bunch of people I mean he did get
convicted of six people and that's a
parking enough he probably killed
considerably more than that um but I
don't know if he was as big a player in
mob circles as he wanted as maybe he
wanted to be you know what I mean
although he did kill people and you know
and he did kill people for for various
like interests so um yeah this is where
we're gonna talk about let's talk about
Mister Softee yeah okay so now in the
early I was like somebody with erectile
disfunction mr. Softee or mr. Limpy BTK
little did a head fell off boy I gotta
understand something
yeah yeah yeah his little hat keeps
falling off what his hats cold all right
oh btw k okay it's like he yes that's
good that all right now um okay so early
1980s robert kuklinski meets this guy
named robert prong gay he's called mr.
Softee because he drove a Mister Softee
ice-cream truck now apparently was a
real functioning ice-cream truck he
would like drive around the
neighborhoods and like sell tea so
apparently that was like his cover
I guess because no one thought that ice
cream truck driver was like a [ __ ]
contract killer that's kind of what he
was
yeah hitman although you know I mean I
this story has always been kind of
fantastical I'm not saying it didn't
happen because crazy [ __ ] happens all
the time I just have a hard time
accepting it but he said it did happen
and this dude did turn up dads of me
that's true maybe it's true and they do
think they do think in this case
kuklinski probably did kill this guy
okay so you know I mean like I said with
DeMeo they're not sure I mean that guy
turned up dead too but from what they
know like the scuttlebutt on the street
was that probably he got whacked by
people in his own career okay this guy
they're pretty stated he didn't get
convicted of or anything but they're
pretty sure that probably he killed this
guy now I don't know if this is true but
Mister Softee said that he was a special
force Special Forces veteran and that he
was a like a munitions or an explosives
expert or something like that I don't
know that's girona um he was also like
like I said he was kind of almost like
he comes across as like a mad scientist
kind of guy like he was really into like
experimenting with like different ways
to kill people and he was really really
fascinated with poisons now apparently
it was his obsession with poisons and
his obsession with cyanide that got
kuklinski into poisons and cyanide as a
way of killing some of his victims
because apparently later on in his
criminal career
Kuklinski said that his favorite method
of murder was cyanide because it was you
know it wasn't easy to
obviously but it was like you know not
very messy you had plausible deniability
it was like and cyanide for protip for
anything like killers out there I guess
it's like it's funny to me because I see
this on the [ __ ] documentaries and
they're saying all this stuff about
cyanide like oh you know it's you just
all you have to do is like spray it up
someone's nose or like put on their skin
it only takes like a tiny tiny bit like
that I saw like I saw one thing that
said like a third of an aspirin tablet
is enough to kill a person sighs you
know I mean that that amount and it's
like oh you know if you it it'll go
through your skin you can like put up
your nose or whatever and it only stays
in your body after you die for about an
hour so unless they're looking for it
there are a couple of telltale signs
like in the lividity like of your skin
after you die but if they're not looking
for it then probably they will not find
out that you were poisoned so it's so I
think that that's why Kuklinski kind of
got into it because it was it's easy to
administer and a lot of times the death
of the person is attributed to natural
causes rather than poisoning because if
you don't know to look for it then they
don't look for it you know what I mean
so yeah so yeah now apparently so like I
said one of his favorite things to do
was like put cyanide looking at one of
those nasal spray bottles and then like
he'd either force it up someone's nose
are just like squirt in their face or
something like that it would kill them
you know I mean so he says that him and
Mister Softee did a whole bunch of
murders together and that it was mr.
softies idea to do the whole body
freezing thing now he says that he did
it a bunch of times
records show that they know of that he
only did it to one person and they know
what they do to this guy cuz they did
find this guy and this was the dude his
name was Louis mask' what they ended up
doing was that they killed him and then
they put him in a freezer I don't like
some story say that they put him in the
freezer in the mr. Softee ice cream
truck and he was in there for like two
years so he was like selling popsicles
and [ __ ] to like little kids like well
there was a [ __ ] body in there
and I think that was in the movie too
just cuz that's more horrible like give
me that fudgesicle that was like right
next to that dude's [ __ ] corpse
um or they might have kept in an
industrial freezer somewhere we I
remembered it it was a freezer that was
inside some kind of a bar that they knew
it might have been because like I said
there there was supposedly a place that
was like behind the bar or some other
restaurant or something and like all the
mobsters hung out there and that's where
they processed the bodies yeah and it
really they had like a couple of them
there at any one time yeah and they'd
let him age up in there for a while and
then let them thaw and then drop him off
somewhere and with the authorities found
the body they wouldn't let the
authorities find the body actually well
yeah because and then the authorities
couldn't figure out what the time at the
time of death was if they were frozen if
you did it right yeah and if they don't
know the time of death of the location
then that really then they can't pin it
on [ __ ] up the investigation yeah
because then like you can you know write
an alibi or anything like that but they
don't like [ __ ] know when you died
you know and that's kind of an important
thing to know in a murder investigation
so apparently kuklinski and mr. Safi had
an argument
according to kuklinski it was when mr.
Softee I keep calling him that you know
that's just better than his real name um
apparently he wanted to contract
kuklinski to murder his son and his
ex-wife and kuklinski would not do that
because like I said he didn't want to
kill women or children so that was kind
of a point of contention between them um
also allegedly mr. Softee wanted to he
was trying to eliminate this one family
and in order to do that he had an idea
that he was gonna poison an entire
reservoir with ricin and kuklinski
didn't much like that idea um so he told
mr. Softee as much hey I don't like that
idea
that's [ __ ] up which is something
coming from a contract killer um well he
wasn't indiscriminate rightly yeah
that's what I mean like he yeah he
didn't think that was too cool that you
were just gonna kill like all these
random [ __ ] people just to get this
one family
we don't like and also like I said he
wouldn't kill women and children he was
kind of like particular about that so
apparently they had an argument about
that during this argument mr. Softee
apparently threatened Kuklinski's family
which was a big [ __ ] no-no if you
ever said that you were gonna do
anything to his wife or children you
were gone you were dead because he
really really felt very Jimmy want you
to know where he lived or where no you
knew where his family lived he'd kill
you right yeah he was very very very
careful about that like I said I think
one guy and this is another story it's
like one guy who either owed him money
or kuklinski owed him money I can't
remember but he's like that guy found
out where he lived and like came to one
of his barbecues one week and he later
whacked that guy just because he knew
where he lives right it was no one else
knew well it was a lapse of security
yeah he didn't want anybody to know
where he lived yeah where his family was
well yeah it made sense well yeah
because look at the kind of people that
you're dealing with [ __ ] and if you
if they know where your family lives
they got later on you yep so you dumb no
not dumb no so so like I said any and
really that's really stupid it was
really stupid for anybody to like
threaten his family because they knew
that was like a big trigger for him so
mr. Softee says yeah well you know [ __ ]
you I'm gonna do this that to your wife
and children so in August of 1984 mr.
Softee was found dead in his ice cream
truck two bullet wounds in his chest
yeah um now at the time of his death
like I said they're not sure if
kuklinski did it or not it seems likely
however um at the time of his death he
was actually right around that time he
was supposed to appear in court there
were like some aggravated assault
charges like against his ex-wife and a
son I guess he had beaten them up and so
he was supposed to appear in court on
those short charges and then he turned
up dead
yeah so it's possible that his ex-wife
hadn't bumped off I don't know now
kuklinski said that he learned a lot
from mr. Softee he did
a lot about poisons and explosives and
weird crazy-ass ways he said crazy has
ways yeah oh he said that guy was crazy
yeah he said that dude was [ __ ] crazy
and he said the more he learned that you
know according according to [ __ ]
kuklinski he said the more he learned
about that guy and the more he learned
from him he realized that he couldn't
let that guy just walk around yeah is he
killed him which you know what if it
really went down that way and then maybe
kuklinski did the [ __ ] society a favor
said maybe maybe and he got referred to
that guy through some other gangsters
yeah and he didn't find him by bite by
chance some other gangsters that he
dealt with said that hey you need to
meet mr. frosty he'll tell you all about
poisons yeah
and that's how he met him from what I
remember yeah he did he did definitely
say in those interviews like I don't
think he confessed to killing him until
later on like in his 2004 interview
which is like his last one but that
would have make a hell of a movie they
well they did put all that Mister Softee
thing in the movie yeah I guess although
like I said they called him mr. freezy
in the movie event he's called mr. softy
in real life let's do that movie it's
good I've seen it a couple of times
Michael Shannon's get it alright thank
you but yeah he plays good once again
that and that's like remember I thought
you saw it with me went under Rider was
in it playing his wife
you don't remember no I've seen it two
or three times it's good so okay so
let's talk about some of the like a few
of the other murders that he was
actually convicted of that they know he
probably committed so this is um
February of 1980 so kuklinski has this
business associate whose name was george
malliband and they were on some kind of
errands they were driving to New Jersey
and according to kuklinski just like
Mister Softee had done george malliband
threatened Kuklinski's family after they
had an argument now at this point so
apparently I don't know what the errand
was that they were running or whatever
they're just driving it they're in this
van so they have a fight he threatens
Kuklinski's family and kuklinski stops
the van and that apparently they have a
fight is like oh you're not gonna kill
me you're not gonna do this is that the
other thing um yeah
Kuklinski pulls out of 38 and shot him
right in the chest five times just
[ __ ] kill them and he just said later
on he said oh it was just business you
know I mean yeah he just got tired of
having him around I think the thing I
think what happened was from what he
said george malliband owed him money and
he said that he didn't have it and that
so they gotten this argument about in
indiana threatened his family and stuff
and then he still after he killed him he
apparently found $27,000 in the
[ __ ] pocket yeah interestingly
he only took how much as much as he was
owed and left the rest of their yeah we
were the thief you know now this guy his
body was actually found they found him
near a chemical plant in Jersey City he
had been stuffed into a 55-gallon barrel
which was something that kuklinski liked
to do yeah now interestingly and he said
because george malliband was apparently
a big dude he was almost as big as
kuklinski himself was and kuklinski like
i said it was six at five almost 300
pounds so he said that he's like I'm
trying to stuff George into the he
called him Georgie boy he's like I'm
trying to stuff him into the barrel and
he was big and he wouldn't fit so he
like had to like cut the tendons of his
legs and like break it like stuff him in
there like that and so like and like I
said when he's saying it on the
interview is just like so matter-of-fact
about it's like oh yeah Georgie boy wait
a minute he's like yeah he wouldn't fit
in the bear this is the one that he just
left out on the street near that no this
is this is a different one they found
this one actually like down he'd like
rolled him down an embankment or
something found that body they did find
this body the guy that he put like by
the hotel or whatever they never didn't
find that yeah they put he killed one
dude put him in a barrel well that's yet
you could talk about that I am gonna
talk okay yeah yeah this is that's the
next one I'm gonna talk about it all
right um so yeah now the george
malliband is that happened they did find
this body this was actually the first
murder that was conclusively linked to
him because he had told someone that he
was going to meet kuklinski about like
some money that was owed you know what I
mean so they knew so the police knew
that Kuklinski
the last person that had seen him alive
they knew that he was going to meet him
that day and then he disappeared so when
they found him dead you know that was
one of the suspicions that came up so
the guy that you're talking about put
the barrel this was a guy named Paul
Hoffman now he was a pharmacist
he was 51 years old Kuklinski met him in
1982
now this pharmacist apparently he hung
out at this place like I said the the
place where the mob hung out like this
kind of you know he was behind like a
bar or a store or whatever where they
used to cut up bodies or engage in
criminal activities or whatever they
were doing back there so he used to hang
out back there now what he wanted to do
was he wanted to buy a bunch of tagamet
which was like an ulcer medication he
wanted to buy a bunch of it on the black
market had a really cheap price and then
sell it at a markup and then make a
whole bunch of money now kuklinski this
was something that he did quite often he
would tell people that he ki can get you
that I can get you videotapes I can get
you drugs I can get you whatever but
then he would never he wouldn't get it
like he he would just like take the
money and then he would just kill you
you know what I mean so that was
something that he did like quite a lot
and that was something that he did in
this situation because he told Paul
Hoffman yeah I can get all that tagamet
for you and you know he agreed to like
set up a meeting or whatever so April of
1982 Paul Hoffman comes to meet kook
lens gets this at this warehouse that
kuklinski had leased Hoffman brings
$25,000 in cash like to buy the tagamet
so he thinks that kuklinski has so
Hoffman gives kuklinski the money
Kuklinski says guess what I don't have
any of that it was just it was all
[ __ ] then he said and he said this
in the interview he puts the gun under
Paul Hawkens chin and shot it with the
guns and like it went in but it didn't
let go all the way in so it didn't kill
him right away so he keeps like trying
to shoot him again gun jammed again so
then he just like beat him to death with
a tire iron because he was like sick of
the gun i guess cuz it wasn't working
see what happened
doesn't make sense to me yeah well
that's what he said okay he said that
the gun wasn't really and it just like
wounded him and like he kind of went
unconscious but then he just like beat
him so that's higher so after that he
puts Hoffman's body in a nother 50
gallon drum he filled the drum with
instant cement and he left it on the
sidewalk outside a motel which was next
to like this diner called Harry's corner
which was in South Hackensack New Jersey
now what kolinsky would do he just left
it on the sidewalk yeah and what he
would do is he would just go like I
don't know if it was every day or every
few days he would go visit it a lot well
he would go to this diner and he would
like eat and he's because he wanted to
listen to like people talking and see if
anybody said anything about the barrel
or if anybody mentioned it they had a
hole in the top of it he said it had a
hole on top of it yeah I mean it was
full of instant cement so maybe that was
like tamping down the smell cuz you
think it would like stink really bad I
think he said it did stink that's what I
thought he said to you yeah you think
somebody would have noticed he didn't
kind of smell it yeah yeah but he said
that for as long as he went there like
he would go there and eat like every day
or every few days and he's like he would
just listen to like the other people
talking about nobody ever mentioned it
and the barrel was always there and he
thought that was really interesting he
said but then he he did that for like a
really long time he didn't really say
how long it was he just said it was a
long time I almost sounded the
impression there was like a year it
might have been but he just said it was
a long time even really remember how
long it was and then one day he showed
up there and the bird was gone
and no one said anything about it know
what happened so he never knew what
happened to it and so he just assumed
maybe it got taken to like a landfill or
something like that they never did find
that Dave's body they never did find
that barrel so nobody knows where that
shit's yeah they know that dudes dead
though I mean he disappeared yeah but
they never did find about goes to show
you back in those days and that might
even apply today about how you can kill
somebody put them in a barrel and leave
that barrel out in public and somebody
else disposed of that body for you yeah
in some ways it might be better to do
that because it doesn't seem suspicious
doesn't seem suspicious and you're
hiding in plain sight and your
fingerprints aren't on that [ __ ]
somebody else took it away yeah well
remember the one we were talking about
before where like people would kill
people just putting them out in the
garbage yeah and nobody noticed on the
side of the and if nobody notices and
they just like take it away and [ __ ]
yeah I mean nowadays they can probably
track it maybe but I don't know once
it's to gets taken to the landfills I
don't know that [ __ ] it doesn't matter
as long as you didn't get your [ __ ]
DNA all over it we have to understand
it's meat yeah all kinds of meat goes to
the landfill right and once it's at the
landfill all kinds of animals will tear
it apart and eating it and the guys that
are dumping at the landfill are used to
seeing [ __ ] animals and [ __ ] and
birds yeah
taryn's [ __ ] up at the landfill well
yeah because I mean look at like we
throw away like chicken fat chicken skin
and you know my critical phase would be
sitting there waiting for him to come
pick it out yeah yeah I mean that would
be pretty nerve-wracking yeah yeah
because if you got busted then you
because they've got it right in Freddy
right out of your [ __ ] house and
they'd be like well obviously it was you
yeah but once they took it away you'd be
like yeah that's some weird [ __ ] man
[ __ ] asleep at night I don't know either
like I said well they're dumb I guess a
lot of them are just dump the garbage
wouldn't you be like thinking that you
were just gonna get like every minute of
every day you would be worried you were
gonna get caught
yeah but we talked about let me talk
about that [ __ ] on another shows yeah
a lot of these dudes were killing people
in own own houses is that same theme
over and over again they just put it out
in the garbage yeah one of their own
[ __ ] house yeah I think out of
stupidity but there's maybe or how see
how stupid could you be I mean it worked
what about the dudes that like come with
cut the dudes up and flush them down as
[ __ ] toilet yeah and they got him
kicked off because it backed up your eye
yeah that's not the good I know I didn't
cut him up small enough glory no would
have been better to just just put him
out in the [ __ ] garbage yeah well he
didn't think it I mean it's like a lot
less trouble and you know you might have
you know 150 pounds 200 pounds worth of
man out there in the garbage it might be
good to spread it out over a [ __ ] a
couple of pickups see I always thought
system that's it respect about this yeah
I always thought in a way it would
almost be better to just like cut them
up and then like throw pieces in like
different dumpsters like around town
maybe although you might get seen maybe
though maybe
Elain help these murderers elantra crime
Raiders so I'm always kind of like
wondering like this is gonna sound
messed up but it's like it's always kind
of like I'm always wondering how could
you have done that differently and not
gotten caught you know what I mean
probably the best thing to do is just
throw them on the side of road let
somebody find him well that's clearly
the best way because that's what they
mostly do cuz that's what they mostly do
and because people never get caught yeah
well one like and we've said this before
it you know if you want to be a serial
killer which please don't do that but if
you want to be a serial killer and I get
just one kill people you don't [ __ ]
know just kill random people and to just
leave them on the side of the road
Zoomer
then we'll never and nowhere around like
via truck driver or yes and just look
kind of like leave them even if they
find them they can't no they can't like
well they can't you know pin them to it
especially if you're not from that state
right yeah
even nowadays I mean you know it's a lot
harder nowadays but you know what I mean
I'm just saying please nobody be here
so apparently so early 1980s so as I
said kuklinski had his little gang of
you know that were stealing cars and
whatnot um but there you know the cops
are kind of starting to like close in on
him a little bit um so a member of the
gang named Percy house was arrested in
December of 1982 now he said that he
would testify against kuklinski who was
the head of the gang so he was put in
protective custody by the police now
there were also warrants issued for two
more members of the gang who were named
Gary Smith and Daniel Det nur now
Kuklinski told them he's like okay well
I need you guys to like really like
[ __ ] keep it on the down low for a
little while and like knock it cuz the
heats coming down on him right so he
rents them a hotel room at a hotel
called the York motel in North Bergen
New Jersey now so they're staying at
this hotel room however cou Klinsky is
not really having a lot of control over
them because they're like wandering off
to like visit their family and show like
he's like look I told you to like stay
there and not go out and not do that and
then he also started to become worried
that one of them Gary Smith was gonna
flip and was being gonna become an
informant and like knew a lot of [ __ ]
about him
and was gonna like testify against him
so he starts thinking I'm gonna have to
kill that guy so he tells Daniel Detmer
the other guy he's like alright well
we're gonna kill Gary so he said well we
had been bringing you know I had been
bringing them food to this hotel room so
it wasn't weird for me to like bring you
know bag of burgers for example except
this time the bag of burgers that he
brought had cyanide on the one that they
were giving it to Gary now at this point
Daniel deaf nerd knew about it he knew
that they were killing Gary so one of
the hamburgers like Gary's hamburger had
cyanide in it um so he gives and he
tells this story like so it's always
it's [ __ ] up because he's like amused
almost he's like so I bring the
hamburger and he's like Gary's eating it
and usually cyanide will like start it
kills you right away like you start like
choking and then like it only takes a
couple minutes to kill you and he's like
I was really surprised because he I'm
he's eating this burger and he wasn't
dying and he's like wool you know did I
put the sign on the right waters was it
not good cyanide or what the [ __ ] is
going on cuz it's like usually it would
you know be fast-acting it work work
right away so he's like watching the guy
going ha I won't know what's going on so
then he says I guess he gets like super
impatient he's like all right [ __ ] it
and then he tells Daniel he's like
wanted to strangle him like starving the
lamp cord
so they did that because decide I was
taking too long
uh-huh that it's not funny but it's like
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] up so they strangled
him and then they sin they put him in
this motel room they put the body in
between the mattress and the boxspring
you know there's urban legends about you
stay in a motel room and there's like a
[ __ ] body out of there and nobody
knows about it
it's real it happened in this case
because they put Gary Smith his body in
the [ __ ] between the bench and the
boxspring five people stayed in that
room without no damn
they said that complained about the
smell oh yeah but I guess it wasn't bad
at which I can't imagine like a man's
body he put in between the boxspring in
the mattress did not feel it I don't
know it must have been a badass
boxspring
yeah or he's like they kind of pushed
him down and the or they hollowed it out
I don't really know yeah
but they put him in like I said there's
freaking urban legends about this but
there's the reason there's interpret
alleged but it's cuz it really happened
well there was that other murder where
that dead girl was underneath the dam
yeah that wasn't my anyone yeah suddenly
Miami people kind of said my past room
kind of smells on and should be dead
underneath there yeah yeah well that's
the thing it's like nobody even if your
room stinks it's like hardly anybody
would think to look between the mattress
in the Box well nothing is that a
[ __ ] human body is massive and when
that shift starts to decompose
I mean it's overwhelmed that's what I
mean it's like so it must've been pretty
cool in there maybe to where it wasn't
really rotten that bad yeah because if
it had been I mean it might not have
been somber in the Florida oh [ __ ] you
wouldn't be able to [ __ ] stand it yeah
like an hour later you can open up what
the [ __ ] you know it would knock you'd
open up the door to the [ __ ] room and
it would just come out of there wafting
out of there
like [ __ ] you know I mean [ __ ] yeah
you wouldn't know the fact that I'm not
sure how long the gap of time was they
said it was like five different like it
wasn't five people but it was like five
different like the birds very cool maybe
I mean if we're talking about 60 50 60
70 I mean this is early was like early I
guess it was January February so much
like and it was in New Jersey yeah cool
so maybe it was pretty cold pretty cold
they didn't see it but it was like the
fifth like family that stayed in this
room finally the smell was so bad that
they couldn't take it so they complained
and when they came in like pulled the
print and then they found the body now
interestingly the pathologist that
worked on the case he said that he's
like they were cut they were kind of
getting sloppy at this point because
he's like one if they had just given him
the cyanide and let him die from the
cyanide and left him on the bed um then
probably his death would not have been
ruled a homicide they would have just
thought it was a drug overdose or
whatever but because they strike not
only strangled him but also hid the body
then they knew it was a murder right so
he's like that was a little dumb
diathesis yeah so now the next person to
get killed was his other associate who
had conspired with him to kill Gary
Smith and leave him
this was Daniel Detmer now this guy
probably thought hey me and kuklinski we
got together and killed this other guy
without thinking that Kuklinski's like
now I'm gonna kill this guy
cuz that's what he's gonna do so after
they killed Smith and left him in the
hotel room he moves Daniel to like this
apartment now the apartment was actually
owned by this guy named rich Patterson
who was at that point engaged to marry
Kuklinski's daughter Marik okay now
Patterson wasn't there at the time but I
guess that kuklinski had the keys or
whatever to the apartment so apparently
they don't know for sure but apparently
he killed um Daniel in this apartment
because they did later find bloodstains
I believe he had cleaned them up but
they found it was luminol or whatever so
he killed the guy in there and then
later when rich Patterson got back he
said I can't believe this you know I'm
not not victim-blaming I'm just saying I
can't believe this guy believed this
story but he's like oh this guy must
have been staying here and somebody
broke in and killed him
we should probably dump this body
somewhere just should not get the police
involved
damn this is the guy that's gonna marry
his daughter yeah yeah and the guys like
okay I'll get rid of this body so they
[ __ ] dumped it in this place that's
like it's only a few miles from I guess
it was like a cabin or somewhere where
kuklinski and his family used to go like
on vacation like horseback riding or
whatever so they dumped him like out in
the woods in what West Milford New
Jersey somewhere now a bicyclist
actually found the corpse they noticed
like this big turkey vulture like eating
something and he noticed it so he kind
of went over there and then saw the body
so the interesting thing about the body
was that the cause of death was
strangling however they said it's very
unusual for a full-grown healthy adult
male to be strangled to death because
that's hard to do right um but they did
notice these pink spots on his skin
which is indicative of cyanide poisoning
if you were looking for it so they
assumed that he must have been
incapacitated by cyanide poisoning and
then later strangled and dumped that's
probably what happened so this was yet
he had no defensive wounds so probably
the poison took effect he just went
unconscious kuklinski probably got
impatient that he wasn't dying quick
enough and so probably ended up
strangling him just like he did with
Gary Smith and like I said that's that's
what I mean when I mean at this point
he's probably getting sloppy because if
he had just let the cyanide work you
know these deaths might have been
attributed to other causes right you
know what I mean because if you're not
looking for cyanide it's very difficult
to detect it does not stay in your
system very long you know other than a
couple of spots on the skin and stuff
like that which I don't even know if
those those might go away after a little
while too but it doesn't stay in your
system if you're not looking for it yeah
so you know it just looks like you had a
heart attack or something like that but
he didn't do that he strangled it
strangled him as well now in September
of 1983 the body of Luis Maz gay was
found in Orange town New York he had a
bullet hole in the back of his head now
this was the guy that had disappeared in
1981 and had been frozen for several
years now what ended up happening with
this guy much like the pharmacist that
he stuffed in the barrel
Kuklinski had told this guy that I can
sell you a whole [ __ ] ton of blank VCR
tapes because apparently the day that's
super valuable he was gonna buy $100,000
with a blank vcr tapes and resell them
on the black market evidently so so
there was this business deal and
obviously there were no videotapes
kuklinski she was gonna take the money
and kill him so this was one of the guys
that on the advice of mr. freeze err mr.
softy rather Robert prong gave who they
were gonna see if they could freeze him
for a long time and then dump him and
see if that would like mess up the time
of death so this was the guy so they did
end up finding the body and it had been
two years since he had disappeared now
the shitty thing about this is that the
thing about freezing a body is that if
you let it thaw all the way
for dumping it then probably you would
get away with it because that does mess
up thinking the time of death because it
would have been because they said when
they found the body it looked like he
had only been dead for a few days right
however the September have been
particularly warm when they took the
body to the coroner and he cut it open
for an autopsy they found ice crystals
right inside the body inside the heart
so immediately he knew okay well this
students obviously been frozen for some
time and has not you know didn't die two
or three days ago as it appeared on the
surface so as I said this was again him
getting sloppy oh if only he had let
buddy thaw for a little bit longer
oh yeah news read some cookbooks about
how long it takes to freeze the thought
you had a thaw frozen turkey well that
you know what it takes is it messed up
that I thought that too because I was
thinking like when we bought that Turkey
how long it takes to freeze it took five
or six days there's lava in the fridge
or in the refrigerant bodies mourn five
days it'd probably take about seven days
to fullfil everything well seven days to
fully thought in a refrigerator yeah you
know I mean outside it would it would
thaw unevenly
yeah I just moved to the refrigerator
and let him sit in there for about a
week until he was nice yeah that's what
he didn't wait long enough he was
impatient patient man well another thing
that he didn't care yeah I think he
didn't get because he hadn't been caught
in so long another thing that he messed
up was that he wrapped the body in
plastic bags which also further
insulated it and you have to you know
kept it from thawing out completely
he'd been killing so many people that
hadn't been deemed caught he was it
wasn't even a suspect that he didn't
care yeah
he thought he was impervious also the
guy was wearing the same clothes that
he'd been wearing as the day he
disappeared two years earlier yeah you
over stripped his ass [ __ ] news oh
they thought that was a little yes also
and like I said when they found the ice
crystals during the autopsy they're like
well clearly this dude but this dude was
killed like two years ago and has been
frozen somewhere like I said they never
determined where he was frozen could
have been in the ice cream truck it's
just totally unlikely hard to find out
when he actually was frozen and who
was around him at the time and
disappearance yeah yeah because it would
be unclear and that's what they were
going to do is they are trying to muddle
try my mother no because the only thing
they're trying to do is try to avoid an
indictment right because if you don't
get indictment if you don't get indicted
then there's never any kind of trial
that's all you're trying to do yeah so
in a way it was good enough problems
yeah now the fact that he had tried to
freeze the body and had like you know it
hadn't thought all the way or whatever
and that he kind of got the reputation I
like I said I don't know if he did it in
more cases than this but this was the
one body that they found they knew he
had kept kept frozen he might have done
it with other victims as well but this
is what gave him the name the Ice Man it
wasn't because he was cold-blooded or
anything like that even though it's kind
of his freezin people that's kind of
like a nice double-sided you know kind
of nice double-sided name there but that
wasn't why they started calling him that
because they because of this guy because
he kept in a freezer now the New Jersey
State Police Detective Pat Kane at this
point he's Kuklinski's on his radar
because one he's been associated with a
gang in northern New Jersey who's you
know kind of like had a lot of [ __ ]
going on and he kind of starts building
a file on the guy and these five
unsolved homicides were attributed to
him because he had been in each case he
had been the last person to see the
victim alive now these were Gary Smith
Daniel Det nur Lewis mask' and George
mallet malliband and also Paul Hoffman
the pharmacist although like I said they
never found his body although they did
find the other four so in 1985 there was
a task force kind of convened and this
was all different you know local law
enforcement state law enforcement
federal law enforcement and they're
going to they called this operation
Iceman and they went after him
specifically because he had been linked
to these five murders and also he was
the head of this gang so what they
started to do was
so who Klinsky had this associate a
friend of his even and in later
interviews he called him a quite a close
friend and even close enough that hid
that this guy and his wife had even like
I think come to his house like for
dinner one time which was a big deal
because he never did that
this guy's name was Phil so limini and
this guy to you this was a guy that
kuklinski later said he was the only
friend I had that I didn't kill this is
the only guy now this guy um decided to
flip and he became a police informant
what he ended up doing was he introduced
kuklinski to an undercover agent who was
a special agent with the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms named
Dominic Paulo thrown now
Paulo phone said that he was and he's
very funny to watch on the documentary
because he comes across maybe this works
out of maybe this works I don't know but
he comes across very much like you know
from a Martin Scorsese movie like a
gangster like that he's like I told him
I was the wise guy from blond you know
what I was so he like told them that his
name was Dominic Michael Provenzano
and that he wanted someone killed and so
he wore a wire I mean he spent a long
time I think it was a year and a half
like he kind of spent time like
ingratiating himself with kuklinski and
his other associates so he wouldn't seem
suspicious like he was just coming out
of nowhere and he kind of slowly like
ingratiated himself into Kuklinski's
circle and eventually like started
talking with him over the phone about
wanting someone murdered now he was
wearing a wire and he got kuklinski to
say all kind of things on this tape
about how he was going to carry out this
hit now later on Paula froa and his
superior speculated that probably
kuklinski was so cavalier about telling
him all of these things because he was
planning to kill and kill like he would
usually do which is why I don't know if
they planned the investigation to go
longer but
some point they were like okay well the
reason that he's telling you all this
stuff is probably because he's gonna
[ __ ] whack you so we need to move on
this like right now but he did get
enough you know like I said he he made
up this fictional person that he wanted
killed it's like it was this cocaine
deal and it's like it went bad it's like
this really wealthy Jewish kid and I
want him bumped off and you know how are
you gonna do it and he would say all
this stuff about the cyanide and he was
like oh really [ __ ] you don't just
[ __ ] plug him with the iron or
whatever and he's like using the lingo
and stuff cuz I've heard the tapes and
then he's like nah man said it's too
messy it's like sign it so much easier
you can just like spray it up their nose
or you can do this and that and the
other thing and you know so they're like
talking very clearly about like killing
this dude so so December of 1986
Kuklinski and Paulo Fran were going to
meet to get the cyanide for this murder
that was supposed to take place so Sao
Paulo forum goes and gets cyanide which
is actually fake that he gets made
somewhere to look like cyanide now
Kuklinski to his credit I guess it was a
weird way saying he was suspicious story
goes that he went somewhere and gave he
put the cyanide quote-unquote on a
burger and gave it to a dog when the dog
did not die he said you know he just
like decided he was gonna get the [ __ ]
out and he just went home so he didn't
like you know continue with the meeting
or whatever he knew about events being
set up because he figured he was being
set up which he was yeah however when he
got on his way home I think he got home
and then him and his wife were going out
to breakfast like a place where they
went to breakfast all the time and there
was a roadblock and basically they got
him out of the car and arrested him now
they pulled his wife out of the car like
put the [ __ ] gun to her head put the
thing in her back and everything like
that and apparently he got really mad at
that and it took like several several
people to like restrain him cuz he was
like very very big dude um because like
I said anybody he beat up that beat the
[ __ ] out of his wife but apparently if
anybody else touched her he got very
very
aggravated and he did in this situation
also she had no idea what was going on
but basically the guy just told her
because she's like what the [ __ ] is
going on why are you arresting us and
all this other stuff all the guys said
to her was like the arresting officer
he's a murderer that's all he said to
her yeah so um they were also going to
charge her because I guess they didn't
keep according to her and according to
him there were no guns kept in the house
like I said he tried to keep everything
very separate he didn't want his family
involved in anything like I said
probably didn't want leverage with all
the scumbags he was dealing with but he
also tried to keep the two things
compartmentalized so we didn't keep any
guns at his house but apparently there
was one that he kept in the family car
so they were gonna charge her I guess is
leverage against him they were gonna
charge her with like a weapons violation
because the car was founded and the car
was in her name and like the gun was in
the car or whatever so he ends up
getting charged with five counts of
murder six weapons violations also
attempted murder robbery attempted
robbery now they think that maybe he was
planning on fleeing the country at some
point soon because he had a whole bunch
of money in Swiss bank accounts he had
flight tickets for a flight to
Switzerland that was you know trying to
get to neutral chair yeah he was trying
to get the [ __ ] out of there
so they think he might have been
planning to run so I guess it was like
probably a good time that they got but
they did today took his passport away
and they put him on a 2 million dollar
bond now several people gave evidence at
his trial including like a lot of his
associates that had flipped obviously
polar firm had been working undercover
for 18 months I believe it was that they
played the tapes at the trial which you
know we're very damning evidence because
they were clearly talking about killing
someone and how they were going to do it
so March 1988 he gets a guilty verdict
he was found guilty of murdering Gary
Smith and Daniel Det nur but because I
guess they didn't give him the death
penalty because it wasn't like a serial
killer type
situation I guess it was almost it was
almost kind of like because it was
business associate or because it was
yeah because of that people who are not
in the United States okay
the United States has a long [ __ ]
history of organized crime especially
Italian mind especially Italian mob yeah
even though this guy was polish or
second yeah it doesn't matter the same
kind of [ __ ] day and there's this
kinda weird
romance America has oh definitely this
type you paid us do a little bit yeah um
like they have put gangsters on the
stand before and those gangsters just
charmed the [ __ ] out of juries and
juries basically acquitted these guys
before
yeah because so like he sees it they're
like well you know what this is between
criminals and this is you know and he's
kind of cool not guilty
well it well III been there's a lot
there's a lot of that and it actually
kind of goes into the how should I say
straight round like Teamsters unions and
unions so we're all linked in with these
same guys well like I said we went into
that a little we went into that before
when we were talking about the art was
talking about the movie called the Irish
the Irishman so is the Irishman so there
are a lot of American unions that we're
it it's not clear-cut where criminal and
I guess you could say citizen where it
Cana in the United States of the United
States is a that's an interesting
[ __ ] is it pretty much criminals all
the way yeah you know it's very you know
I say I mean especially when you start
politics when you get into politics
it is Crimmins are all [ __ ] criminals
yeah they're all criminals is just
there's not a lot of different now
they're all crime well and the thing is
I don't think here's the thing if
kuklinski had just killed other
gangsters I don't think everyone would
be just like but because he admitted one
he admitted to killing animals yeah [ __ ]
that um - you know what I mean
especially kitties don't yeah yeah
you know he's a little boy a little boy
up for that I will kick your little kids
ass if they do yes [ __ ] damn I can't
ever [ __ ] touch art can you ever
touch Pookie you're [ __ ] dead that's
what I mean all right and I see my word
yes Danny knows I said yeah like I said
general like I probably I probably eat
you in a steer I would [ __ ] kill you
if you don't [ __ ] yeah don't [ __ ] do
that
like I'm sorry there's just there's no
excuse there's notes that's like killing
some bees child that's right I mean
that's like killing a baby yeah knock it
off
but you know if he had just killed other
gangsters everyone you know it would
just just be like you know a lot of the
mafia stuff White's romanticizing stuff
because mostly they were just killing
other gangsters and everyone's like yeah
who cares because they're like they're
all dirtbags and they're all in that
same game and they're all the same and
they know that you know they get into
the [ __ ] and they know that that's
what's in a halter right but the fact
that kuklinski admitted one killing
animals to killing random ass people
just in the street just then okay then
[ __ ] him you know what I mean it's
that's what I mean if you had just
killed other gangsters no one would be
on Friday that's all right because he's
just killing other scumbags or other bad
dudes it's like no one would care it's
like what everybody loves Dexter even
though it's a fictional character
because he only kills other Jerry okay
I'm not gonna say I'm not gonna I'm
gonna go as far to say that all of the
American gangsters that are mob mobster
types are scumbags because that's just
not really true I'm just using that as
said yeah yeah they're in another game
it's another culture it's another
culture if you want to call it that for
the most part there was honor in a lot
of that there were some [ __ ] birds and
[ __ ] bags and rats you know I mean they
had that but that's between them I'm not
gonna get involved in that [ __ ] that's
their that's that's that's their thing
and like I said they know what they're
getting into
when they do it it's like nobody goes
into gets into the [ __ ] mob without
knowing we're all getting into everybody
knows that you have to understand the
origins of the mob the mob actually can
go back and
Italy during the [ __ ] times of the
[ __ ] Muslim conquest when they were
in occupied territory the only the only
representation the Italian people had
were these mobs because they were they
were being occupied that was hardly
years ago back turn you know I mean pre
guess you could say that was it was pre
Crusades era that's where a lot of that
should have started evidently according
to legend so I understand the tradition
you know but that's just the Italians
there were organized crime there were
organized criminals going through all
throughout Europe and the United States
where it had it had a different origin
but the Italian mob actually has a very
long history and in a way you could say
they were kind of like an underground
legitimate government for a while yeah
it almost gets to that yeah point I mean
once it gets there are no are not
reaching yet whether or not they
maintained that that's on you to believe
that or not a lot of it had to do with
just money making a hustle and the
little guy trying to get his piece I
totally understand it just watch them
watch some good movies on it yeah that's
good fellows or the Irishman yeah yeah
they weren't [ __ ] lazy scumbags they
were at least working quote-unquote
working yeah their money not always
legally yeah general they were supposed
to be men of Honor
yeah in general in jail like I said I
think a lot of in work they would
generally they would only kill you if
you did something circuit like you
didn't pay them back or you did
something to [ __ ] or do ratted or
something so there was a you know what I
mean we may have some of them out there
in the audience I'm just gonna say that
yeah yeah we don't know what can I
understand you know they have their own
warrior we feel that way and they were
doing with that I get that and I respect
it's a tough world out there
I get that now I'm learning more about
the Mexican mob and there's there's an
amount of respect there I mean they got
[ __ ] bags just like there are [ __ ] bags
in any organization but I can understand
the situation that they're into I mean
they're in Mexico a government doesn't
really represent them a government
that's kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] over the
economy of Mexico and yet these little
guys who are trying to make money
somehow narcotics are involved [ __ ]
the the cops aren't [ __ ] doing [ __ ]
so who actually is in charge difficult
to say in Mexico
Mexico's that what you can understand
how this happened you can understand how
it evolves yeah you know I mean you can
say well it's against the law you guys
well who's in control of the law in
Mexico those dudes aren't any good
either
yeah you know so I understand well like
I said it's understandable and like I
said if if this guy had just killed like
it had just been like paid it's like hey
whack this other [ __ ] that did this
that and the other did did a terrible
thing
it heard this other criminal it's like
no one would really care but like I said
because he confessed that he killed like
just random people walking on the street
which could have been you or me and he
killed animals which like I said I'm not
done with that sorry no no kill animals
bro that's what I mean killing children
that's like killing it being out and I'm
a hunter there are game animals and pet
animals you don't kill pets yeah you
know I mean that's I mean that's [ __ ]
up it's like killing humans baby the
game game animals are deer and rabbit
herbivores who are highly but even then
if they're gonna kill them you're gonna
eat them you're gonna eat and you kill
them you mainly exactly you don't kill
them to like you don't make them suffer
no no no it's not for your amusement
all right a [ __ ] a [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] a game animal in general is a
herbivore they have high reproductive
rates you kill them with honor through
the hot it's quick and you come you go
over the oldest ones the ones that have
already reproduced [ __ ] like I'm not big
into you know me okay I come in from a
real culture I'm not into this trapping
okay trapping and that's [ __ ] up I
think trapping is [ __ ] dishonorable
yeah I'm not into these omnivores you
don't kill [ __ ] like possums and
raccoons okay that's not a game animal
yeah okay a game animal is a herbivore a
rabbit a [ __ ] deer I kind of even
felt like a murderer a killing all those
goddamn squirrels okay because you got
to kill 50 of them to have a [ __ ]
meal okay there are little bitty little
things let the squirrels live let the
squirrels live but don't [ __ ] kill
the raccoons and the foxes and the
Coyotes those are dogs yeah those are
dogs leave them alone well it's like you
can't really yeah I mean you can eat
them if you have to but it's like that's
not really the way I look at it is that
predators and omnivores okay have they
don't have as many children in a litter
yeah they're not meant to be eaten they
you know I mean they haven't evolved for
that they're eating berries and
occasionally things like meat but
they're herbivores are prey animals they
have a lot of children yeah because in
the wild is innate why their playdate
yeah get her being eaten and those are
the ones you're supposed to eat yeah
[ __ ] like predators and omnivores you're
not really supposed to eat them yes
you're not supposed to eat bear you're
not supposed to eat [ __ ] cats
you're messing up you're not supposed to
Uncle Ben yeah you're [ __ ] up the
ecological balance they don't have many
children in a litter and and here's the
deal [ __ ] Birds and Yankees and [ __ ]
they'll [ __ ] kill that kind of [ __ ]
but people from the country know that
they've not eating that yeah you know
they're eating deer they're eating
things that have a lot of children and I
don't really like eating rabbits I think
they're kind of small plus they're
adorable yeah I used to have a pet
rabbit named scooter Oh kind of this is
my kind of see I see them all as equal
and kill a [ __ ] beer and you could
eat off that for a long period of time
it's one life you take it you give
thanks to the [ __ ] animal spirits
yeah it's like it like just like the
Indians you know debate and that one
life can sustain you for a long time
a rabbit can't sustain you for yeah
they're very little you know you like I
said it's there you know it's different
if you're like you know in as your
stylist vibration sure no one's gonna
like get on your ass about it then but
really for just a game situation dear
yeah and deer that have lived to
reproduce yeah that have already have
already reproduced I didn't live their
lives yeah they were there they have
evolved to be eaten that's how they've
evolved they have you know I mean they
[ __ ] deer reproduce quickly yeah yeah
so um alright so as I said like at his
first trial which was just for two
murders he actually his defense trying
to argue that like you know the [ __ ]
that he said on the tape about like
killing the dude he's like oh I was just
like um making stuff up because I wanted
to impress this dude that was in the mob
that's what he tried to say like on the
tape and everything but they're like ya
know so he did actually get a guilty
verdict now there was supposed to be a
second trial that was going to be for
the murders of george malliband and
louis mass gay but because I guess
kuklinski didn't want the hassle so he
just said well you know what I'll just
plead guilty there's okay I killed those
two guys so now the murder of Paul
Hoffman the pharmacist who he allegedly
put in the barrel put the cement and
then left it outside the hotel by the
diner
he was gonna be convicted of that but
they didn't have enough evidence so they
basically said okay if you confess to it
and like kind of help us find the body
although I don't think they ever did
find it then we will drop the charges
for that murder and we will also drop
the charges against his wife for the gun
possession and also I think his son had
had like some [ __ ] like marijuana
possession charge or something like that
he's like well drop that charge too if
you confess to that one as well
so he did so for those four he was he
got two 60-year sentences you know one
for the first two guys and the one for
the second two guys those were gonna be
a concurrent and so he would not he
would have been eligible for a parole
but not until 2046
now in 2003 he also admitted that he had
killed this other guy and we'll kind of
get into that a little bit so we're
gonna get into that yeah a little bit
and this show is going on three hours
this wall it's almost over okay so this
was a this was the sixth murder that he
confessed him and this was until 2003
was always a already in prison um in
1980 there was an NYPD detective named
Peter Calabro who had been murdered
now kuklinski confessed to this he said
he got another 30 years for this
although it wouldn't it mattered cuz he
was never gonna get out anyway he said
that the Gambino crime family or a guy
from the Gambino crime family named
Sammy the bull Gravano had paid him to
kill Peter Calabro now Kuklinski said
that at the time that he killed this guy
he said basically he's like I took the
van it's like the road was covered with
snow I kind of pulled over so the cars
had to go around me and then I hid
behind a snow bank and when the guy
drove past he came out and he just like
[ __ ] blew his head off with this
sawed-off shotguns like shot his head
off like he did it that other guy so he
said he did that um he said that he
didn't know that it was a cop he was a
crooked cop he was like you know on the
take from the mob or whatever he didn't
know it was a cop at the time but they
asked me they said well if you had known
it was a cop would you have done it he
said yeah yeah anyway because he got
paid for doing so apparently Sammy
Gravano who had allegedly paid him to
kill this guy was in prison for drug
drug trafficking at this stage he also
got indicted for the murder and
kuklinski was going to testify against
him now Sammy Gravano his lawyer said
that because of this whole brouhaha that
kuklinski had tried to extort $200,000
from Sammy Gravano just from this whole
situation and the FBI later confirmed
this fact so there had been that kind of
[ __ ] going on now Kuklinski was supposed
to testify against Gravano in this case
however kuklinski died
in 2006 and after that they dropped
those charges now Gravano was still in
prison for 20 years for drug trafficking
but they were gonna indict him for this
because he had supposedly paid for this
guy to be bumped off and they were gonna
try him for that and kuklinski was gonna
be the main witness but he died so
apparently he died of natural causes but
some people still think so now in the
interviews like I said and we talked
about this a little bit earlier in the
interviews he basically said he had
killed like I said every interview which
were they were a few years apart the
total kind of went higher and higher
like eventually you know it's like at
first it was kind of like oh maybe a
hundred and then later it was like oh
maybe 200 maybe 300 but say they just
kept like getting more and he said that
he used pretty much anything he was not
like particular about one method of
murder he would stab you we would shoot
you he would poison you he would use a
crossbow
he said he blew somebody up with a
grenade oh he would you know put people
in cars and like set him on fire he
would do all this kind of stuff now he
did say that he liked cyanide the best
because it was like the easiest to
conceal or whatever he said at one time
and I don't know if this was confirmed
or not but he said that apparently
either he was he was tasked to kill this
guy or this guy just pissed him off and
he just wanted to kill him for whatever
reason but it was like in a gay bar and
he's like so he said that he dressed up
as the gayest gay ever like he said he
put on like the loudest outfit dancing
around and he said he went out there and
like danced and stuff and it's so fun
it's like funny in the interaction is
exposed 5ya gangster hardest well that's
what he said that he's like is [ __ ] I
would love to seen it yeah and like I
said I don't know if that happened or
not but yeah he had a bunch of cyanide
in damn in in a glass like a nice little
bit on the guy like it was an on
accident and then whoa I'm sorry I'm
sorry then walked away and that dude
[ __ ] died and he died allegedly of a
heart attack yeah yeah
now was that verified I don't know see I
think that's one of the ones that he
might have made it just made it but you
know what that's a good I
yeah that's what I mean it's like I was
like that when I was like hearing all
the stuff about cyanide and even some of
the people that were like even like some
of the forensic scientists and stuff
were saying about science like oh it's
very hard to detect if you're not
looking for it it's like it doesn't say
your body more than I'm like yeah it
happened in public and everybody saw it
but he played it off like it was just an
accident the club it's like everyone's
bumping in everybody spilled drinks and
stuff like that so he's like so I
thought that would be the easiest way to
do it like on a crowded dance floor cuz
no one would notice you there was a
video game called hitman yeah and
[ __ ] some of those missions were
[ __ ] difficult like that makes sense
yeah makes sense that something like
that would happen okay yeah he's just up
as a gay yeah it's funny
he was almost trying he was almost
trying to like not it for some reason
this is hilarious to me but like in the
interview when he was describing this
incident whether it happened or not I
don't know it sounds like it could
happen well he was almost like the way
he was talking he was he was like trying
not to offend gay people which I thought
was he's a he's a killer yeah and he's
like well I don't want gay people to be
mad at me yeah because I'm saying oh I
was swishing around he's like wait is
that offensive it was kind of like that
which I thought was like very weird he's
like you're talking about killing
someone and you're like afraid that
you're gonna like offensive body that
you're [ __ ] dressing like I don't
know it was like really I would like to
get down to the bottom of that it was
really a lot of this stuff I don't know
because he had I mean like I said he
told the story about the crossbow thing
like he just shot this random dude like
that he was gonna ask for direction he
just shot him in the dude with a crew
you know in the head with the crossbow
yeah if it would work yeah I don't know
what crossbow he's talking about but I'm
gonna tell you this you know cuz I have
my own boat you know [ __ ] I was a bow
hunter and I got my [ __ ] I got a
whole high country [ __ ] compound bow
and I had a bust that [ __ ] out on a
Rambo day what at one of these days
Rambo Rambo day its kind of its kind of
like a hundred twenty pound full on it
but he said he used a crossbow and shoot
somebody in the head and it went half
way through my experience the [ __ ]
arrow goes right through and keeps on
going like nothing even happened he said
it went half
way through the gun I don't know what
kind of crossbow he was using it might
be pastor might have had a cheap one or
something that was didn't have a whole
lot of a [ __ ] pull on it yeah because
my bow it go through [ __ ] five heads
yeah that's what I mean it's like I took
archery in high school and I mean we
even have like not even crossbows cuz my
brother had a crossbow for a while but
we even had just one of those compound
bows and that would go through yeah that
would go through some [ __ ] yeah I got
[ __ ] out there broadheads [ __ ] I
got [ __ ] poison pods I got everything
out there he's kind of I got poison just
a [ __ ] few grains of that [ __ ]
old-fashioned poison [ __ ] in your in
your bloodstream is just kill you deader
than [ __ ] in a few seconds yeah I got
some of that back and that's [ __ ] 80s
that's that's the [ __ ] poison we had
from the 80s I'm sure she's still legal
it's probably not so you know I
shouldn't have said that out good he's
got all kind of stories like I said he's
got stories about like tying dudes up
and put him in the cave and the cave
rats eat them he said that one time in
Rio de Janeiro that he killed these two
drug dealers and castrated them he also
said that the he caught a rapist in
Miami and like castrated him also and
then threw him into the ocean and then
he got eaten by sharks so it's like did
he do some of the [ __ ] probably it
sounds shitty I do definitely killed a
lot of people he did he did but like I
said later he might have like
exaggerated because I think he liked the
publicity and the attention and the
attention like a lot of those guys to
you yeah um you know what I mean now
they asked him if there was ever any
murder that he had regretted and he's
like well not really but he's like there
was this one he didn't regret killing
the guy but he regretted the way he did
it he said there was this one guy I
don't know if it was one that he just
killed for his own personal reasons or
because he got hired to do it but he
said this guy he's like he was just
crying and praying and everything yeah I
know he got hired to kill that guy I
think yeah and and he was like so
basically he was his apart
he was crying and [ __ ] so much that he's
like okay I tell you what I'll give you
half an hour and if God comes down and
intervenes in a situational that's good
then I'll let you go and then he's like
well half an hour later he's like you
know God did not come down God did not
change the circumstances so that was
that and he said all he said was I
shouldn't have done it that way he
didn't say I should have killed that guy
he just said I wish I hadn't done that
forever correctly it also turned out
that his girlfriend was hiding in a damn
closet death was in the movie I'm not
sure if that's what really I remember
now remembers and they might have
literally said it if he let her go
he might have and because he had a thing
he would not know women are too and then
I think I think that in that same case
he covered up that murder by planting a
bomb yeah that blew up he did say you
blew up a guy with a grenade one time
yeah at least one times been a long time
since it's been long time since I've
seen you
yeah I think that he [ __ ] hit by
blowing up a bomb in there and people
thought that he that that the victim was
making a bomb and blew himself up I
think that was in the movie too I think
they dramatized that in the movie okay
because the thing about the girlfriend
being in the closet and all that I think
pretty sure that was in the movie tail
I've seen it a couple times too it was a
long time ago that I seen it from what I
remember from the interview he realized
that there was somebody in that damn
closet he pulled her out and talked to
her and said the [ __ ] tolerances this
is just business
yeah and she was like don't kill me he's
like if I let you go will you say
anything she says I would never say
anything cuz she didn't ever really know
yeah that was it yeah they put that in
the movie that she didn't really know
the guy that well she goes okay and get
the [ __ ] out of here
yeah and then he let her go well as you
would I mean it's probably on the same I
mean especially if you didn't know that
guy that well you didn't know him that
well she'd just been some like six foot
five dude told me and that I just saw
like kill a guy and I'm not saying a
worker from formula I remember he said
he took her ID and all her information
yeah and said so he never she we will
find you a few [ __ ] shoes I would
never say anything and then [ __ ] which
yeah if you're smart right like I said
cuz you just saw what the [ __ ] happened
right so I'm like I said so now how
reliable are the
flames of him of being now he says that
he worked for all five of the big crime
families in New York City you know all
of them as well as the very famous de
Cavalcanti a crime family of New Jersey
and he says that all of them at varying
times hired him on contract hits it
wouldn't surprise me if that happened
but we're not talking about the guy at
the top guys yeah we're talking about
the mid mid-level guys from all those
families in the lower level guys
wouldn't surprise me yeah if he got a
lot of business from front from the
Lowell house although like I said a lot
of the crime families themselves the
people that have talked and like you
know people that have worked undercover
and stuff like that they're not sure how
reliable his claims are because he says
that for example he says that he was one
of the hit men that helped to
assassinate Paul Castellano who was kind
of the boss of the Bonanno crime family
that was in 1979 or in uh no that was 85
and then there was another guy named
carmine Galante who was supposed to be
killed in 1979 that was the Bonanno guy
Paul Castellano was from the Gambino
family he said that he was involved in
that and those were really big like
high-profile gang hits he said he was um
involved in both of those like that he
he didn't say he was the only hitman but
he said he was involved or that he was
there or he was one of the hitmen and
sources close to the crime families as
well as people that investigated the
crime families say that is unlikely um
he also said that he that John Gotti had
hired him to kidnap and murder John
Favara
who was the guy who accidentally killed
John Gotti's 12 year old son after he
hit him with a car and killed him and
kuklinski said that John Gotti hired him
to kill that guy
and that is also a dubious claim he's
trying to write himself into he also
said that he was one of the people now
when they first asked him because when I
saw one of the interviews one of the
interviewers like that they did for HBO
they asked him about Jimmy Hoffa now we
talked about the Irishman and we talked
about it um Frank Sheeran saying that he
was the one that killed Jimmy Hoffa and
you know that they burned him in an
incinerator what not the first time that
they asked
Kuklinski about Hoffa he kind of hemmed
and hawed implying that maybe he knew
what happened but that maybe he was
there maybe not like he was very cagey
about it
however later on he said like at first
he said he knew who killed him but then
later he said no it was me gottam he
said what happened he said yeah I killed
him and then he they put his body in a
you know in a 55-gallon barrel like a
drum like you know kuklinski would
usually do and then they set the body on
fire and then they welded the drum shut
and then buried it even though they
killed him in Detroit they said they
drove the barrel all the way back to New
Jersey and then buried in a junkyard and
then he said that you know they thought
that somebody might find the body
because someone was gonna flip that new
one were that knew where the body was so
they took the drum they dug it up they
put it in the trunk of a car that was in
the junkyard and then it got compacted
like it got crushed and then that
crushed metal got sent off to Japan and
made into other cars [ __ ] so that
was his story [ __ ] I believe that
most likely what happened is Jimmy
Hoffa's body just like out of the movie
that Irishman was sent to a mortuary
just incinerated it that was that they
owned and they incinerated it just like
all the other bodies and spread the
ashes so because these guys did it seems
like very the easiest date most obvious
thing they had resources they didn't
have to go to those kind of weird
lengths to get rid of a
they just got rid of the they got rid of
the body the way you get rid of all
other bodies you put it in a damn more
tree incinerator burning ashes and the
thing is if you stress all the DNA you'd
never be alone in the mob if they are
associated with owns a mortuary so you
do it conveniently that's how you do it
you could have a mob fronting yeah but
that would be a smart thing to do they
have them yeah dad I'm rid of bodies
like that like you would get rid of
regulars like anybody no one would ever
find it it makes so much more sense
before I believe that maybe some of the
stories that he was buried underneath
the dam stadium that was under
construction at that time that the mob
agatized it no it would be though it was
much trouble it would have been the most
logical thing you take him to the
mortuary you got leverage with and you
have him [ __ ] burnt down into ashes
just tore along with the rest of the
bodies well and the reason that I mean
one you know there's not a lot of core I
mean obviously nobody knows what happens
to Jimmy huh what happened to Jimmy
Hoffa I mean he was reduced to death
maybe Frank Sheeran knows maybe he did
kill him I don't know but um he was
reduced you know I'm just
well no I'm saying like Frank Sheeran
like in the movie the irony like maybe
he did have something to do with it
I don't think who's kolinsky had
anything to it because like I said at
first he just said he knew who killed
him and then later he said oh I did it
but then this elaborate thing it's like
one if you killed the guy in Detroit why
would you drive him all the way like
somebody pointed out it's like look
Detroit has one of the biggest lakes
yeah in the world yeah like I want to
just dump it in the bottom of the lake
no whatever fine why would you drive it
although hit max buck in New Jersey it
throws and risking Cod you know I lived
in Detroit you could go to a random
[ __ ] abandoned building and throw
those ashes in the corner of a [ __ ]
room and crush any kind of teeth that
you might see and that [ __ ] will
never be found yeah cuz they're gonna
[ __ ] bulldoze that old building along
with the rest of this [ __ ] they
bulldozed yeah in Detroit
Detroit was like straight out of the
crow yeah yeah so I kind of feel like a
lot of his kind of higher-profile look I
always involved in this that and the
other like I I don't think so
and honestly like one of the writers
like one guy that write a biography of
him that actually like interviewed him
at length he apparently like was making
a joke with kuklinski one day and he
said I have a feeling if I listen
to you long enough you'll tell me you
shot President Lincoln yeah and
kuklinski apparently thought that was
very funny inside yeah you're probably
right yeah so you know I I think that he
kind of exact like I said he was a
cold-blooded killer he did kill many
people he liked to tell his stories but
I think that he liked to kind of you
know a great little bit so like I said a
lot of a lot of the murders that he said
he committed have not been substantiated
I'm not saying he didn't commit them I'm
just saying they haven't been
substantiated or connected to him I
think he killed I think he could a lot
of low-level gangsters yeah and maybe a
few mid-level ones I don't think he was
as well-connected as he said but I never
thought that yeah because most of the
claims that he made was a pretty just
like local right low level dudes that he
[ __ ] killed because some another
low-level dude hired him to do it yeah
and he never claimed to be in part of
any kind of family yeah he never he
never did claim that he did say that all
five of the major New York crime
families and one of the major news hires
one hired him for various jobs I have a
feeling that it's low-level guys and
this man has never hired like hey here's
$40,000 go because I don't think he was
the kind of guy that [ __ ] the dudes
at the very top wanted to be associated
with probably not those guys we actually
weren't that violent and weren't that
mirtha weren't that violent we weren't
that murderd murderous at the top yeah
they were trying to live kind of normal
lives a lot of guys well I'm gonna what
this is kind of a [ __ ] up thing kind
of say but you have to I mean this was
their business it was their livelihood
it's like yes they killed people
obviously if people you know obstructed
what they were trying to do or whatever
and they would bump you off if you were
like [ __ ] with them but in the
aggregate they were just trying to make
a lot of money now if they needed to
kill you to accomplish that goal they
would do that right but kuklinski was
all he was about killing people not some
I mean he did make money but his heel he
just killed [ __ ]
he wasn't so yeah he did it for free he
yeah he didn't like he got mad he'd do
it right so he wasn't the kind of guy
that dudes at the very top of the Mafia
would walk around them
he seemed like it would be it won't show
me David call off he's unpredictable
like I can see how that would be
valuable if you needed some dirty work
yeah you can call on I got like if you
don't want him around your family I
don't because clearly he could do it
without any remorse or without caring
about it or without care even without
caring about getting caught really
because he didn't really seem to be all
that careful about it so I could see how
that might be a valuable asset to have
around but like I like you said you
wouldn't want him having like a high
position in your organization because he
had this kind of like I think he was
this temper where you weren't really
sure when it was gonna like you know
blow it over and kill you right I think
he basically you're dealing with you
doing basically a mass murderer yeah
that the mobs families knew about and
some of the guys at at the bottom in the
middle organization would access him
every now and then to [ __ ] take care
of an enemy but I don't really think he
was you know [ __ ] too much in the
Mafia per se yeah I mean all he did was
kill people yeah I mean he didn't really
start too many businesses he tried to
get into the porn copying business and
he had kind of a burglar like a car
theft year and that's the bottom of the
barrel for the mob
it is the top of that's low level yeah
the top of the mafias [ __ ] like owning
casinos owning [ __ ] running running
[ __ ] unions that's the top yeah you
know not this you know hitman jobs yeah
like I said this is just like dirty work
is this like [ __ ] you need to get done
because somebody's in your way or yeah
are they [ __ ] you over or whatever yes
I think he's blown is important portents
out of [ __ ] I think that's know like I
said but he was killing he's a terrible
person he did kill a lot of people but I
do think that he inflated his you know I
don't have a sauce I'm what I do have a
soft spot for him he had a [ __ ] rough
childhood he grew up his head grew up as
a badass he didn't have much of area
honestly now and
and you know I mean he was killing bad
guys mostly occasionally although he
beat the [ __ ] out of a wife - yeah
that's not cool either but he was just a
weird guy
yeah very strange guy although like I
said he's fascinating to listen to yeah
yeah so he's very entertaining to listen
to yeah like well creepy yeah
entertaining because like I said he's
very calm yeah he's very calm like I
said earlier he's the only guy out of
this show so far that scared me
I am I did not want that dude around me
I understand that yeah because like I
said he just didn't care about anything
yeah if you just like I said it won't
sound like that is that he's a
professional about it and he hadn't had
physical [ __ ] power physical strength
he knew how to deal with weapons and
poisons and he could deceive you
yeah and you know I mean it poison you
you know yeah he was bad I mean
apparently like even some dude like even
if you did something as minor like I
said it's like maybe cutting him off and
trafficker apparently like somebody just
like flicked him off one time cuz he did
something that pissed them off or
whatever you killed that guy yeah well
he was a rage monster yeah and you might
set that dude off and right uh yeah and
you're not dealing with some [ __ ]
wannabe [ __ ] [ __ ] this dude was the
[ __ ] serious badass yeah serious and
like I said he was a big giant big
[ __ ] city got a 5 dude and he didn't
need guns he could use his [ __ ] hands
yeah and he did yeah or even just used
whatever was it any wasn't some kind of
weird hated serious sexual pervert he
was just no he didn't be a baby didn't
care about that he was just a badass I
mean [ __ ] I don't want to [ __ ] with
him
yeah and like I said mr. kuklinski this
mr. Kutz I'd be at mr. Comiskey sir all
times I'd be walking on eggshells around
that dude yeah I can see how everyone
would yeah so apparently so he's um he
was in prison for 18 years and then he
gets diagnosed with what they call
Kawasaki disease okay
is that like a Yamaha syndrome yeah yeah
hotter sickness it's apparently well I
guess together discovered it was named
Kawasaki so that was like that's like
when your blood vessel blood vessels
become inflamed so he gets sent to a
medical center in Trenton New Jersey now
like I said he seemed to think because
he was going to you know be the star
witness at the Sammy Gravano trial for
you know the murder trial he seemed to
think that someone was poisoning him I
don't know if that's the case
like I said they did an autopsy after he
died apparently and they didn't find
anything out of the ordinary it looked
like he had just died of a heart attack
but he seemed to believe that people
were going to poison him because he was
going to you know testify at that trial
and I mean maybe because Sammy Gravano
did actually get off on that okay
because they they dropped those charges
because you know Kuklinski was their
main thing so he gets sick they take him
to the hospital now his wife Barbara um
who still has his last name because she
said you know I could have changed it
but she's like I she she almost like the
name seems she hated him but she almost
like wanted to keep the name like to
spite him kind of I think it seemed like
so she had actually divorced him in 1993
but she still kept visiting him even
though she hated his guts
but she kind of like let it lapse so she
would only come like once a year or
something now when he was dying she came
to visit him one last time I believe
that one of the daughters was with her
even though his children mostly like cut
all ties with him as he would but she
came to visit now
Kuklinski specifically asked look if I
flatline please resuscitate me now
Barbara who was still you know I guess
even though they had divorced I guess
she still had like had power of attorney
or whatever it was like over him she had
signed a do not resuscitate order
you know and I guess that like uh you
know
I guess since he was in prison that kind
of like you know was over whatever he
wanted so the thing is so she said and I
and I watched his interview with her
there's like look she visited him I
think a week or two before he died and
she's like I didn't say anything to him
at the time it's like I kind of knew he
was dying but they when I was leaving
they asked me it's like do you want to
rescind this do-not-resuscitate
instruction and she said no Hilda I do
not now she said later on like after he
died cuz he did die about a week later
she said the only thing I regret is that
the last time I visited him I didn't
tell him what a bastard he was and how
much I hated his guts she's like I wish
I would have told him that so that would
have been the last thing that he heard
for me before he died put him through a
lot and [ __ ] you know he was abusive
to him yeah the agretti he regretted
that he did but like i said in a lot of
ways he said he was sorry but then he
said i couldn't have been that sorry
because i kept doing it he couldn't help
what he was i guess not but like i said
that's no excuse he was what he was yeah
you know he was not a [ __ ] normal guy
yeah and he [ __ ] very paranoid yeah
and a control freak
oh yeah and when that [ __ ] happens
that's how it's gonna come out yep the
people around I'm gonna suffer yeah
although I think he regretted that
that's what he was he did um and he did
he did say that he regretted it and he
did say that he wished they would
forgive him but like I said he said I
couldn't have been that sorry I look at
it it's almost kind of like a mental
illness well clearly and like I said
when I watched you know when he asked
the psychiatrist in that last HBO
interview when he asked us at well what
do you think of me you know that's you
know dr. Dietz he went into this big
long thing about the things that he
thought were the matter with him he's
like look I think that you probably
genetically were programmed to have this
thing where you had you know
fearlessness or maybe like somewhat lack
of empathy that probably came from your
family and then interspersed with you
know or intertwined
with this like this horrible way that
you were brought up he's like and also I
think you have like it's kind of a
paranoid personality to sort of where
you you know the slightest you know any
kind of criticism or any kind of slight
or anything like that it makes him like
blow up and look you know turn into a
rage monster he's like so some of that I
think it's genetic and he's like but you
know had you been raised in a loving
household you probably would have
channeled that into more positive
energies like I said being like a test
pilot or doing something like that but
because you are raised in a really
[ __ ] up environment and didn't have
any love didn't have any role models and
didn't have anything like that it kind
of sets you off on this path and there
was really no way of avoiding that once
you were in that atmosphere so he did
like kind of lay it out for him that it
was like a nature versus nurture he's
like some of it is genetic probably but
because of your upbringing you know you
were kind of doomed from the start which
I think he kind of was yeah I mean his
[ __ ] brother got killed by his dad I
mean yeah man his other brother [ __ ]
murdered a rape and murder two girls do
that I mean it was like I said he was a
man of his place and time he was coming
out of a [ __ ] really violent [ __ ]
she is and like I said I'm not excusing
it because you know some people a lot of
people grow up in environments like that
and turn out fine that was his religion
but because he had a genetic
predisposition and we talked about this
a lot on the show about serial killers
and stuff because he had a genetic
predisposition of that type of
personality yeah those two things
together yeah that's a recipe for
disaster if you were if you had
genetically were like not programmed to
be that way and you had a fucked-up
childhood you probably turn out okay you
know being obviously you'd have
automatic part of his genetic
predisposition was his size he had
physical power yeah there's no reason
for him to [ __ ] turn inward and
become a [ __ ] passive person it's
more in his favor to [ __ ] go outward
and [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah yeah I
mean that's what he became yeah well
they're light for his own [ __ ] you
know gotta fight for his own space and
in the end I
we'll think that this guy you know he
wasn't a sick twisted [ __ ] sexual
[ __ ] like some of these other he
was he did have a warrior profile he was
well what's a good place of what's good
way to put it he he was just in a very
unfortunate circumstances I think I kind
of understand him in in a certain way
yeah
I'm he's dead now let that [ __ ]
read rest in peace you know what I mean
I mean he had a he had a really bad
upbringing bad childhood was around a
lot of bad people and he became my I
said he wouldn't bother me if he had
only killed that they're gangsters yeah
if you'd only killed other gangsters
talking about he was so focused on other
gangsters that he didn't consider
civilians as being anything maybe that's
what it was you know like I said he did
too much into it because he killed
animals because he got random people
because he beat up on his wife yeah and
threatened his children so focused I was
bucked up he was so focused on people he
thought were dangerous and had to go and
was a way of money is that nothing yet
other people didn't really [ __ ] even
come into it seemed like nobody really
registers like didn't registers of the
people I don't II was only looking at
people who he think seemed when he talks
he seems not entirely human yeah like
it's not all there um and so I think
that he projected that onto others his
his his vision of what reality was is
different than the average person yeah
definitely he was totally in the game
yeah totally in the game and seriously
if you somebody I don't remember who it
was but somebody on YouTube put all
three of the HBO interviews and watch
it's about two and a half hours yeah
it's like it's creepy but it's
fascinating because I don't know it's
like one he has like a real a weirdly
like soothing voice cuz he's just very
calm he doesn't one time he gets a
little bit upset like with the
psychiatrist but not to a point where
he's like yelling or anything he's just
kind of like what you're almost
right there and like you can hear a
seething anger underneath
yeah he's haunting back clearly wanted
to kill that guy but he kind of shrugged
it off he's like and he was kind of
trying to he went almost a little like
introspective like he was kind of trying
to examine his feelings about why he
wanted to do that yeah and the
psychiatrist I mean obviously he's used
to I mean this psychiatrist had been
he's interviewed Dahmer he's interviewed
like all other serial killers so he was
not intimidated he just wanted to know
why so he kept asking him it's like well
why you know why did that make you
almost like what happened is it because
I challenged you you know is it because
this is not in the other so he kind of
kept asking him what like to examine why
his his feelings about why he wanted to
do me I always [ __ ] enjoyed watching
him because it was a weird hybrid
between professional soldier and
criminal I could I could understand a
lot of what he was saying yeah being you
know X infantry and stuff I could
understand a lot of it
well one thing that he said really
struck me and I thought this was kind of
insightful about what he said well the
psychiatrist kind of like led him into
this but he kind of like agreed to it
he said that because of his upbringing
he's like he learned that to care about
anything was a weakness yeah that could
be used against you that could be right
and that's so when the psychiatrist said
that to him he's like he he immediately
like understood that he's like yes
that's exactly right he's like if you
care about anything it is a weakness
that can be used against you and so that
was the way he saw the world well he was
go back telling the audience go back and
watch his [ __ ] the [ __ ] is a war
machine but it's not a normal war
it's a mafia war I understood it I I I'm
glad I'm not like that
but I do understand it yeah well like I
said he's interesting from that
standpoint because it was a little
extreme for my from my point of view I
come from a world where his uniforms and
clear-cut divisions between friend and
enemy yeah I mean and I understand the
concept of frenemy he lived only in the
world of frenemy
yeah because a lot of the plot of the
[ __ ] enemies he killed were his
friends yeah I wasn't that walking yeah
yeah he said that he's like even said
well some of the people said oh I really
liked that dude but then you know he got
inconvenient for whatever reason just
killed him and he didn't feel bad about
it and he had to have some he just like
well had to he had to [ __ ] muster a
lot of psychological strength not to
have an organization and a whole legal
system behind him to support what he was
doing yeah this is an individual doing
it on his own yeah for his own benefit
money and like you said I think deep
down he really understood he was doing
this isn't some dumbass who's just
[ __ ] he understood exactly what it
was he was doing yeah and deep down like
he said I do think he felt something
yeah at least for his children because
he did kind of like get emotional and
tear up when he started talking about
them and how he would do anything for
them so I do think I don't think that
was [ __ ] I don't know who's faking
and another thing is I want to tell the
audience is that a lot of these other
[ __ ] serial killers that we're
talking about they have sexual motives
to me they're not interesting to me I
would just [ __ ] smash those [ __ ] I
don't know because they don't even have
the depth to understand what they're
doing they don't understand the [ __ ]
impact of what they're doing right they
kill they kill some woman just because
basically they want to bust a nut yeah
and they don't think anything of it
because there's nothing to those dudes
yeah there's nothing to them to think
about it Kuklinski knew the implications
of everything that he did yeah he knew
yeah hit you don't mean didn't strike me
as no he was not this sociopaths
Psychopaths type he knew full well what
he was doing and knew the implications
of what he was doing but he had
rationalized and weighed and judged
everything as well this is an enemy it's
an enemy gangster I'm hired to do this
contract
this guy's an evildoer he would have
done the same to me I'm gonna go ahead
and [ __ ] do this
to get him out of the system and move on
even people he killed randomly were
people that did some
thing too annoying yeah yes so he
probably justified it that well this
dude very much like a [ __ ] cop or a
judge jury executioner like Judge Dredd
really yeah he did seem very much very
much like that and he had made himself
like not care about it because he had
been doing it for so long right that
well [ __ ] him he was wrong I'm a killer
yeah I think that's exactly where he
crossed the border have some cognizance
of them yeah he knew everything about it
he did seem to know that that's why he
was doing it he knew exactly and he knew
that it wasn't normal
yep nits he knew it was wrong you knew
it was but he said you know is his is
his view was the well something has to
be done yeah yeah it did kind of come
across like that I think of it as like a
parallel government or a parallel
[ __ ] justice system yeah but it's a
cricket it is not a criminal justice
system is a justice system and being
beeping it's a justice system being
applied by criminals yeah yeah that's
exactly what it is right well yeah
that's it you know in a way that's
that's what makes him different from a
lot of the others you talk about and
that's why I find I'm so interesting
like I said because you brought him up
but you know what I'm on a show before I
was like oh we should probably do a show
about that guy cuz he is I called him a
mass murderer and he's one of the most
interesting and mass murderers he is
very interested like I said I don't
justify anything it's like he's a [ __ ]
up dude obviously but yeah he did have
psychological problems clearly but you
know he's interesting to examine from
that George he's kind of like yeah he's
kind of like a unique individual in that
regard yeah alright so we are going to
wrap up episode 174 hope you guys
enjoyed it's probably like super long as
it usually is because we use our dragon
and start talking you know how we do
remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you would like to financially support
the show that would be much appreciated
all your contributions will be used
toward you know making the show better
to pay intervals do whatever it is
[ __ ] car fix that we just spent 1200
[ __ ] dollars on yeah but yeah so if
you would like to do that you can go to
our patreon account patreon Comic Con
cast or if you go to our blog 13 o'clock
podcast WordPress
there's a button in the sidebar to a
PayPal account where you can give a
one-time donation if you would like to
do that and with that we will bring
episode 174 to a merciful close we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]